Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Citizens of San Gimignano, heed well my words. You must repent, repent and seek forgiveness, for your wicked ways have incurred the wrath of a demon. Summoned by your sins, he now walks our world, cloaked in shadow and darkness, and everywhere he treads, death follows. Why, you ask?
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。圣吉米尼亚诺的市民们，仔细听我的话。你们必须忏悔、忏悔并寻求宽恕，因为你们的邪恶行径已经招致了恶魔的愤怒。因你们的罪孽而被召唤，他如今正行走在我们的世间，披着阴影与黑暗，他踏足的每一处，死亡便如影随形。你们会问，为什么？
Because you have strayed and sacrificed your liberty to that wretch Lorenzo de Medici. You are puppets, enslaved by purse strings, won over by poisonous words. You have lost your virtue. You have lost your dignity. You have lost your faith. And this draws the demons into feed. And feed they will. So that was a priest called Antonio Maffei addressing the people of San Gimignano in
因为你们已经误入歧途，将自由献祭给了那个可怜虫洛伦佐·德·美第奇。你们是提线木偶，被金钱所奴役，被恶毒的言语所折服。你们失去了美德。你们失去了尊严。你们失去了信仰。而这吸引了恶魔前来吞噬。而且他们必将吞噬。所以，刚才那位是名叫安东尼奥·马菲的牧师，他在向
Tuscany and it is a speech that follows one of the most dramatic episodes in the history of the Renaissance, perhaps indeed in all Italian history, and that is the Pazzi Conspiracy, which was a plot to murder Lorenzo the Magnificent, who is head of the Medici family during high mass in the cathedral, the Duomo in Florence on the 26th of April 1478. People alert to the nuances and rhetorical rhythms of Florentine rhetoric in the 15th century, may be wondering whether that speech was actually made by Antonio Maffei or whether it was made up very possibly for a computer game. So Dominic, what's the answer? Because that doesn't sound genuine to me. It's not genuine, Tom. It's a scene from the video game Assassin's Creed 2, which I heartily recommend to the listeners. A brilliant game set in Medici, Florence. In reality,
托斯卡纳的圣吉米尼亚诺人民发表讲话，这段演讲紧随文艺复兴史上、乃至整个意大利历史上最戏剧性的事件之一——也就是帕齐阴谋。这是一个旨在谋杀美第奇家族族长、伟大者洛伦佐的阴谋。事情发生于1478年4月26日佛罗伦萨大教堂（圣母百花大教堂）的大弥撒期间。对15世纪佛罗伦萨修辞学的细微差别和修辞节奏敏感的人，可能会好奇那段演讲究竟是安东尼奥·马菲本人的讲话，还是极有可能是为了一款电脑游戏而虚构出来的。那么多米尼克，答案是什么？因为这听起来不太真实。Tom，这确实不真实。这是电子游戏《刺客信条2》中的一个场景，我向听众们强烈推荐这款游戏。这是一部以美第奇家族统治下的佛罗伦萨为背景的精彩游戏。实际上，
Mafay, who definitely existed and plays a big part in this story, he was in no condition to give such a speech since he had just gone under the knife in a peculiarly excruciating way. Oh, so this is delivered after he's gone under the knife? No, I think they cut in the game him going under the knife. Okay, because in which case I should have done it in a slightly higher pitched voice. You should indeed, but we'll give that moment to you, Tom, don't worry. Okay, something for listeners to look forward to. Exactly. The fact that this moment plays a part in a best-selling video game tells you, I guess, something about the enduring reputation of Lorenzo the Magnificent.
马菲——他确实存在，在这段故事中也扮演了重要角色——当时根本没有状态发表这样的演讲，因为他刚刚经历了一场极其痛苦的手术。哦，所以这段话是在他做完手术之后发表的？不，我想游戏中剪辑了他去做手术的画面。好吧，如果是这样的话，我刚才就该用稍微高一点的声调来读了。你确实应该那样，不过没关系，Tom，我们把那个高光时刻让给你。好吧，这倒是个让听众们期待的看点。完全正确。这个时刻竟然能在一款畅销电子游戏中占有一席之地，我想，这说明了伟大者洛伦佐那经久不衰的名声。
By any historical standards, he is a figure of extraordinary glamour and romance. He is the embodiment of Renaissance Florence at its peak. Now, last time, in the last episode, we looked at the foundations of Medici power in Florence, in particular, Lorenzo's grandfather Cosimo. And today, we're going to look at Lorenzo himself behind the myths of his magnificence and we will concentrate particularly on the story of the Pazzi conspiracy, this amazing kind of Godfather 2 style conspiracy that almost destroys him. So shall we start with Lorenzo himself? Why not? Yeah, I know you'd love that. So he was born on the 1st of January, 1449 in Florence. His father was Piero de' Medici, who was the son of Cosimo, who we talked about last time.
按照任何历史标准来看，他都是一个极具魅力和浪漫色彩的人物。他是处于巅峰时期的文艺复兴时期佛罗伦萨的化身。上一次，也就是上一期节目中，我们探讨了美第奇家族在佛罗伦萨权力的基石，特别是洛伦佐的祖父科西莫。而今天，我们将把目光投向洛伦佐本人，揭开他“伟大”光环背后的神话，我们尤其会集中讲述帕齐阴谋的故事——这个惊人的、犹如《教父2》风格般的阴谋差点将他摧毁。那么，我们从洛伦佐本人开始讲起好吗？为什么不好呢？是的，我知道你很喜欢这样。他于1449年1月1日出生于佛罗伦萨。他的父亲是皮耶罗·德·美第奇，皮耶罗则是我们上期节目中谈到的科西莫的儿子。
And Piero is being groomed to succeed his own father as head of the Medici political network. Lorenzo's mother, now we haven't actually had any women in the story really at all. So it's nice to have one. His mother is called Lucrezia Tornabone and she came from a rich patrician family and she was a remarkable person actually. She's very religious. She's very keen on the arts. She is a poet in her own right.
皮耶罗当时正被精心培养，以继承他父亲的美第奇政治网络领袖之位。至于洛伦佐的母亲——说实话，我们的故事里其实一直都没怎么出现过女性，所以能有一个女性角色真好。他的母亲名叫卢克雷齐娅·托纳布尼，她出身于一个富有的贵族家庭，实际上是个了不起的人物。她非常虔诚。她对艺术充满热情。她本身就是一位女诗人。
She writes hymns. She writes verse translations of the Bible. She sounds brilliant. Yeah, she is brilliant. Everybody says Lucrezia Tornaboni is a very very accomplished and impressive woman There was the other one who was jolly and fat in the previous episode a Contesina Yes, who's his grandmother fat and capable and cheerful. I think was the description. So what about Lucretia? Is she she's not fat She's capable. Is she jolly? I think if you're writing verse translations the Bible Bible by definition you're not jolly, surely.
她会写赞美诗。她会撰写《圣经》的韵文译本。听起来她太棒了。是的，她确实很棒。每个人都说卢克雷齐娅·托纳布尼是一位非常有才华、令人印象深刻的女性。上一集里还有另一个胖乎乎、挺快活的女人，孔泰西娜。是的，那是他的祖母，又胖、又能干、又开朗。我想当时的描述就是这样的。那么卢克雷齐娅呢？她……她不胖，她很能干。她开朗吗？我想，如果你在写《圣经》的韵文翻译，按定义来说，你肯定不会是个快活的人吧？
Necessarily. So, Lorenzo has three sisters and he has a younger brother called Giuliano and Giuliano will return in this story in a thrillingly blood-stained way. So Lorenzo is said to be a very ungainly boy, but he's good at sports, Tom, which will please you and he's very clever. And he has a classic kind of mid 15th century humanist education from his private tutors. Classical, you might say. Classical education, loads of Latin, loads of Aristotle, loads of Plato now because people
不见得。总之，洛伦佐有三个姐姐，还有一个弟弟叫朱利亚诺，朱利亚诺将在本集故事中以一种令人心惊肉跳、血迹斑斑的方式再次登场。据说洛伦佐小时候是个非常笨拙的男孩，但他擅长体育，Tom，这会让你高兴的，而且他非常聪明。他的私人家庭教师为他提供了典型的15世纪中期的人文主义教育。你可以说，这是古典式的教育。古典教育，大量的拉丁语，大量的亚里士多德，现在还有大量的柏拉图，因为人们对柏拉图狂热不已。
are getting really excited about Plato. By the time he's 15, his family are already training him for a life in politics. He's been sent on diplomatic missions to Pisa, to Milan, of course, Florence's big ally, to Bologna, to Naples, and so on. When he's 17 in 1466, he goes to meet the Pope, Paul II, to Rome to discuss something that is going to, again, play a part in this story. Something that matters a lot to the Medici Empire, which is they have a concession for
到了15岁时，他的家族就已经在为他日后的政治生涯做准备了。他被派往比萨、米兰（当然还有佛罗伦萨的坚定盟友米兰）、博洛尼亚、那不勒斯等地执行外交任务。17岁时，即1466年，他前往罗马拜见教皇保罗二世，讨论一件将再次在这个故事中发挥作用的事情。这件对美第奇帝国至关重要的事情是，他们获得了托尔法一个地方的
alum mines in a place called Tolfa. Alum is a kind of mineral, mineral salts that you use for dying. And you make a lot of money from it. And this mine is really important for the Medici. And as you will see, its importance has consequences. And why is the Pope into this? The alum mines at Tulsa are in the papal states. So they're under the Pope's kind of jurisdiction.
明矾矿的特许开采权。明矾是一种用于印染的矿物盐。通过这可以赚大笔的钱。这座矿对美第奇家族来说非常重要。正如你将看到的，它的重要性会带来相应的后果。为什么教皇会卷入其中？托尔法的明矾矿位于教皇国境内。所以它们受教皇管辖。
He's granted the Medici a concession. Right. Now by this time his life has already changed because his grandfather States, so they're under the Pope's kind of jurisdiction. He's granted the Medici a concession. Right. Now, by this time, his life has already changed because his grandfather Cosimo, the godfather of the family business, has died of his gout. So that's where we entered last time. Now, Cosimo, as people will remember, is not a duke, he's not a prince or a king. He is the de facto ruler of Florence because he's the head of the bank and he's the head
他授予了美第奇家族特许权。好吧。此时，他的人生已经发生了改变，因为他的祖父科西莫——家族企业的教父——因痛风去世了。这就是我们上期节目结尾的地方。现在，正如大家所记得的那样，科西莫不是公爵，他不是亲王或国王。他是佛罗伦萨的实际统治者，因为他是银行的掌门人和
of the political network. So when he dies, Cosimo, it's not actually guaranteed that Medici influence will continue. Because I guess, I mean, we compared him to Augustus in the previous episode. Yes. And Augustus has this kind of officially voted raft of powers, doesn't he? But Cosimo doesn't have that. It's much more shadowy for him. And so it's a question of can he maintain the bonds, the dues, the networks?
政治网络的领袖。所以当他去世时，美第奇的影响力是否会延续其实并没有得到保证。因为我想——我的意思是，我们在上一集中把他比作奥古斯都。是的。奥古斯都拥有官方授予的一系列权力，对吧？但科西莫没有。对阴暗面的掌控对他来说要多得多。所以问题在于，他能否维持住这些纽带、人情和关系网？
Exactly. The person who succeeds is Lorenzo's father, Piero. He is accepted pretty smoothly as the new head of the family. But is he really up to it? Piero is 48 years old at this point, and he's a bit of a wreck, to be honest, he has massive eczema, he has arthritis and he, of course, he has this gout, so actually people call him Il Gotoso, the gouty, he's known as Piero the gouty. He looks very unappealing, he has massively swollen glands, his eyelids droop so he appears to be constantly asleep.
正是如此。接替他的是洛伦佐的父亲皮耶罗。他相当顺利地被接受为家族的新领袖。但他真的能胜任吗？此时的皮耶罗已经48岁了，老实说，他身体有点垮了。他患有严重的湿疹，有严重的关节炎，当然还有痛风，所以人们实际上叫他“痛风者皮耶罗”（Il Gotoso），他被称为“痛风者”皮耶罗。他看起来非常不讨人喜欢，腺体肿得厉害，眼睑下垂，看起来像是在 constamment（不断地）打瞌睡。
But actually, he's a smart guy. You see, I had always kind of imagined him as Jeremy Strong. No. And I realize that that's because he's playing a role slightly analogous to Jeremy Strong's character in Succession. No, he's much more impressive than Kendall Roy. Yes. He looks very sleepy, but
但实际上，他是个精明的人。你看，我以前一直把他想象成杰瑞米·斯特朗。不。我意识到那是因为他在扮演一个类似于杰瑞米·斯特朗在《继承之战》中角色的角色。不，他比肯德尔·罗伊厉害多了。是的。他看起来很困，但
he's always thinking and he's a methodical, he's a famously methodical banker. So actually, I think he's a reasonably impressive person. So he's underplayed in the historical record. I think he's underplayed exactly because he's head of the family for only four and a half years. So he's easily forgotten and it's not smooth sailing actually. So when he takes over, he asks for a report. He says, like, I want to have a report on the family finances on the state of the Medici Bank. And he is shocked to find out that they have overextended themselves a bit. There's a lot of turbulence in Northern Europe and they basically loan too much money. And he says, right, we should cut back on credit some of these big spenders, actually people
他一直在思考，是一个极其有条理的银行家。所以实际上，我认为他是一个相当令人印象深刻的人。因此他在历史记载中被低估了。我认为他被低估了，恰恰是因为他只当了四年半的家族掌门人。所以他很容易被遗忘，而且事实上并非一帆风顺。所以当他接手时，他要求看一份报告。他说，我想看一份关于家族财务状况和美第奇银行现状的报告。结果他震惊地发现，他们的步子迈得有点大，过度扩张了。北欧有很多动荡，他们基本上贷出了太多的资金。于是他说，好吧，我们应该削减对其中一些大肆挥霍者的信贷，实际上比如
like Edward IV, King of England. He's a massive spender, isn't he? Massive spender, very extravagant. Or the dukes of Burgundy. And he says, we've also loaned too much money to the Florentine elite. Let's call in some of these loans. But actually calling in the loans means that some of the Florentine elite go bankrupt. And this triggers a bit of a crash in Florence itself.
英格兰国王爱德华四世。他是个大手大脚的人，对吧？挥金如土，非常奢侈。还有勃艮第公爵。他说，我们还贷了太多钱给佛罗伦萨精英阶层。让我们收回其中一些贷款。但实际上收回贷款意味着佛罗伦萨精英阶层中的一些人破产了。这反而在佛罗伦萨本地引发了一场小型崩盘。
So there's an economic crash. There's then a split in Florence itself. So there's an economic crash. There's then a split in the Medici party. Some of the old guards say, oh, Piero's, what's he canceling all the loans for? This is terrible. And this comes to a head in the summer of 1466. Actually, you mentioned succession. It's a very succession scene.
于是发生了一场经济崩盘。接着，美第奇党内部也出现了分裂。一些老卫兵说，噢，皮耶罗他在干什么，为什么要取消所有的贷款？这太糟糕了。这在1466年夏天达到了白热化。实际上，你刚才提到了《继承之战》，这真的是个很《继承之战》的场景。
So the sort of hangers-on of the Roy family in succession, they're all called Carl or whatever, these kind of old guys. These people in the Medici story say, Piero's not up to it, and they call for an end to Medici domination and they say, let's go back to the old free Republican system. And Piero shows that despite his gout, he does have the backbone, he does have his father's ruthlessness because he immediately spends a load of money bringing in troops from Milan.
因此，《继承之战》里罗伊家族的那些跟屁虫们，他们都叫卡尔什么的，这些老家伙们。美第奇故事中的这些人说，皮耶罗无法胜任，他们呼吁结束美第奇的统治，并说，让我们回到以前的自由共和体制吧。而皮耶罗则展示了，尽管他有痛风，但他确实有骨气，他拥有他父亲那种冷酷无情，因为他立即花了大笔钱从米兰引进军队。
He raises a private army of mercenaries. He brings them into the center of the city the day before the Signoria elections. And the opposition kind of panic and crumble. The elections go his way. They're banished from Rome and Piero is able to cement his power. I mean, you've got to say that being a senior banker in the 15th century Florence sounds a lot more dramatic and fun than maybe being one today. Yeah.
他组建了一支由雇佣兵组成的私人军队。在领主委员会选举的前一天，他将他们带入了城市中心。反对派顿时陷入恐慌并土崩瓦解。选举按他的意愿进行了。反对者被驱逐出罗马，皮耶罗得以巩固了自己的权力。我的意思是，你不得不说，在15世纪的佛罗伦萨当一个高级银行家，听起来可比现在刺激有趣多了。是的。
It's not just sort of VIP tickets to Wimbledon. No, it's eliminating your enemies by bringing in paid mercenaries. Who wasn't want to do that? Everyone loves that. But actually, this is the side of the Medici story, you see, that we often miss. Because people think it's all kind of fancy palaces and Renaissance paintings like a thousand or more different versions of the Annunciation. But actually what you miss is the kind of armed intimidation, the election rigging, the sort of political
不仅仅是温网的VIP门票那么简单。不，是通过引入付费雇佣兵来消灭你的敌人。谁不想这么做呢？每个人都喜欢这样。但实际上，正如你所看到的，这就是美第奇故事中我们经常忽略的一面。因为人们以为这全都是些豪华宫殿和文艺复兴时期的绘画，比如上千种不同版本的《圣母领报》。但实际上你忽略的是那些武装恐吓、操纵选举、某种政治
gangsters, sort of mafia politics, I think, to some degree. And that's the aspect you admire. That's the aspect I like. I can take or leave some of these paintings of, you know, the Annunciation and what. They're all the same, ultimately. What have you got against the Annunciation? I just think there's so many of them. Oh, you can never have too many. Or indeed the Adoration of the Magi. They're very keen on that as well.
黑帮、某种黑手党政治，在某种程度上是这样的。而这正是你欣赏的方面。这正是我喜欢的方面。至于其中某些《圣母领报》之类的画作，我可看可不看。到头来它们都长一个样。你对《圣母领报》有什么意见？我只是觉得这类的画太多了。哦，这种画永远不会嫌多。或者说《三王来朝》也一样。他们对这个题材也非常热衷。
Yeah, exactly. So I was in Florence a few months ago and Tabby, our assistant producer, said, how's it going? And I just said, listen, if I see another painting of the Annunciation I'm gonna go mad. But what if it's an Adoration of the Magi with a giraffe? Well we'll come on to the giraffe later on. But the art is part of the story because like Cosimo, Piero was very keen on artistic patronage. He spent a lot of money on coins and stuff for churches. Brilliant. I love him. On manuscripts.
是的，完全如此。几个月前我在佛罗伦萨时，我们的助理制片人塔比说，情况怎么样？我只是说，听着，如果我再看到一幅《圣母领报》的画，我要疯了。但如果是一幅带着长颈鹿的《三王来朝》呢？嗯，我们稍后会讲到长颈鹿。但艺术是故事的一部分，因为就像科西莫一样，皮耶罗非常热衷于艺术赞助。他在硬币和教堂的物品上花了很多钱。太棒了。我爱死他了。还有手稿。
He was a big fan of Donatello. We talked about Donatello last time, the sculptor. When he died, Piero paid for him to be buried next to Cosimo, next to his father. Wasn't Donatello a teenage mutant ninja turtle? He absolutely was. That would mean nothing to most of our listeners who are all under the age of 15. No, but it means something to me, Tom. And it's Piero who actually promotes a young painter called Sandro Botticelli.
他是多纳泰罗的超级粉丝。我们上期节目谈到过雕塑家多纳泰罗。他死后，皮耶罗出资将他安葬在科西莫旁边，也就是他父亲身旁。多纳泰罗难道不是一只少年神龟吗？他绝对是的。这对我们绝大多数年龄在15岁以下的听众来说毫无意义。不，但这对我来说有意义，Tom。而且正是皮耶罗提拔了一位年轻的画家，名叫桑德罗·波提切利。
So he was Atana's son and he gets Botticelli to actually come and live in the Palazzo Medici and treats him as one of the family. And if you go to the Uffizi Gallery, you mention the adoration for the Magi. Botticelli's painting of that in the painting are Cosimo and Piero and one of the young men on the right is the young Lorenzo the Magnificent. And you know what this reminds me of? What? Our appearance as donkeys in... Oh yeah, Malcolm Price's novel. The Welsh noir novels of Malcolm Price. Yeah. So anyway, Lorenzo. So Piero the Gaudi is the boss, is the new godfather, and he's pushing Lorenzo forward.
他是塔纳的儿子，皮耶罗让波提切利搬来美第奇宫居住，并把他当作家人对待。如果你去乌菲兹美术馆，你刚才提到了《三王来朝》。波提切利的那幅画里，画着科西莫和皮耶罗，右边的一个年轻人就是年轻的伟大者洛伦佐。你知道这让我想起了什么吗？什么？我们像驴子一样出现在……哦，对，马尔科姆·普莱斯的小说里。马尔科姆·普莱斯的威尔士黑色悬疑小说。对。不管怎样，说回洛伦佐。所以痛风者皮耶罗是老板，是新教父，他正在把洛伦佐推向台前。
And one of the elements of pushing him forward is they have to get him a wife. So he's 18, and Piero and Lucrezia are looking for a wife for him. The fact that they're looking for a wife when he's only 18, which is young by Florentine standards, is a sign that they are beginning to rank themselves alongside the kind of the princes and the aristocratic families of Europe. Because princes get married young. But to remind a point made in the previous episode, in Florence, if you remember the aristocracy, you can't run for office.
而将他推向前台的其中一个环节就是，他们必须给他找个妻子。当时他18岁，皮耶罗和卢克雷齐娅正在为他物色妻子人选.他们在他只有18岁时就开始物色妻子——按佛罗伦萨的标准来看这还很年轻——这表明他们开始把自己与欧洲的王公贵族相提并论了。因为王子们结婚都很早。但为了呼应上一集提到的一个观点，在佛罗伦萨，如果你属于贵族阶层，你就不能竞选公职。
Right. Exactly. So is this starting to change by this point? I mean, the Medici have reaching a point where they don't have to worry about Lawrence, if you remember the aristocracy, you can't run for office. Right. Exactly. So is this starting to change by this point? I mean, the Medici have reaching a point where they don't have to worry about this or what's going on? They can't become aristocrats. They want to live like aristocrats and they want aristocrats abroad to treat them like aristocrats.
对。完全正确。那么此时这种情况开始改变了吗？我的意思是，美第奇家族已经达到了某种地步，他们不用再担心如果你属于贵族阶层就不能竞选公职了？还是说情况发生了什么变化？他们不能成为贵族。他们想过着贵族般的生活，并希望国外的贵族像对待贵族一样对待他们。
Right. So it's very telling. Lorenzo's bride will be a foreign noblewoman, a young woman called Clarice Orsini. She's 16 years old. She's an heiress from Rome. Her family have bigger states near Naples. Lucrezia goes off to Rome to meet her and inspect her at Mass at St. Peter's. And she reports back.
所以这很有说明意义。洛伦佐的新娘将是一位外国贵族小姐，一个名叫克拉丽切·奥尔西尼的年轻女子。她16岁。她是来自罗马的一个女继承人。她的家族在那不勒斯附近拥有较大的庄园。卢克雷齐娅动身前往罗马去见她，并在圣彼得大教堂的弥撒上审视了她。随后她汇报了情况。
She says to Clarice, she's all right. She's got a round face and red hair. And I quote, she's tall and not got a round face and red hair and I quote she's tall and not unattractive her face is not pretty but it is not common and her figure is good altogether I think the girl is a good deal above the average. So it's kind of 15th century hinge. Yeah it's. Now what about Lorenzo is Lorenzo a catch?
她对克拉丽切的评价是她还行。她有着圆脸和红发，我引述一下，“她个子高，没有圆脸和红发，我引述一下，她个子高挑，不算难看，面容虽然说不上漂亮，但也并不平庸，身材很好。总的来说，我认为这个姑娘远高于平均水平。”所以这有点像15世纪的相亲。是的，它是。那么洛伦佐呢，洛伦佐是个好夫婿吗？
Well people say Lorenzo looks a little bit unconventional. He has long dark shoulder length hair. He has a long broken looking nose. He has a kind of jutting jaw and a kind of glowering angry brow and his voice we're told is nasal and high pitched. And when I read those words Tom, you know who I thought of? I know exactly who you thought of. And he's listening in as we record this right now. I thought of Theo Young Smith, the producer of the rest is history.
人们说洛伦佐长相有点非主流。他留着长长的深色齐肩发。他有着一个长而看似骨折的鼻子。他有着向前微突的下巴和一副怒目而视、气势汹汹的眉毛，而且据我们所知，他的声音带有鼻音且声调很高。当我读到这些词时，Tom，你知道我想到了谁吗？我完全知道你想到了谁。而且他在我们录音的当下正在收听呢。我想到了西奥·扬·史密斯，《历史的其余部分》的制片人。
Because, of course, we're also told that Lorenzo was very charming and energetic and clever and the parallels are uncanny. It is Theo. They really are. Although Lorenzo has slightly grander taste in clothes than Theoodosy. You know right there's jewelry and stuff No, oh, it's harsh. They looks like he's just coming off the street. Whereas you'd never say that of Lorenzo I can't believe you've gone there Tom, but you have theory Please remember who it was who said he praised you as charming clever and who said you look like somebody off the street
因为，当然，我们也被告知洛伦佐非常迷人、充满活力且聪明，这种相似之处简直惊人。这就是西奥。确实如此。尽管洛伦佐在服装上的品味比西奥要稍微盛大一些。你知道的，有珠宝之类的东西。不，噢，这太刻薄了。西奥看起来就像刚从街上走过来的一样。而你绝不会对洛伦佐这么说。我真不敢相信你居然会这么说，Tom，不过你确实说了。西奥，请记住是谁说你迷人聪明，又说你看起来像个路人。
So anyway, Lorenzo marries this clarity che. I was about to say it's not a great love affair, although they do have 10 children, but he's not faithful. He has mistresses, whatever. Well, he's the magnificent, isn't he? Yeah, do what he likes. That's the kind of thing. If you call them magnificent, that's going to happen. What does he like doing? How does he spend his time? He loves a bit of sport. He plays a kind of football. So again, like Theo, who's very good at football.
所以不管怎样，洛伦佐娶了这个克拉丽切。我本来想说这不是一段伟大的恋爱，尽管他们确实有10个孩子，但他并不忠诚。他有情妇，诸如此类。好吧，他是“伟大者”，不是吗？对，想干嘛就干嘛。就是那种情况。如果你被称为伟大者，这种事就会发生。他喜欢做什么？他是怎么消磨时间的？他酷爱体育运动。他玩一种足球。所以，就像西奥一样，西奥非常擅长踢足球。
Yeah, but he plays a calcio fiorentina, which is 27 players on each team I think it's too many. He plays a kind of fives called Paloni Now he loves a prank and a joke not quite at the standard We're used to on the show though Peter the great or sort of Augustus the strong or Charles the 12th standard Yeah, but you see thing is I think that their japs are quite menacing You wouldn't want to be caught up in you know in something involving bellows or bears or anything like that. No, that's not the race that's fired.
对，但他玩的是佛罗伦萨足球（Calcio Fiorentina），我想那是每队27名球员，人数太多了。他玩一种叫做帕洛尼（Paloni）的墙网球。他喜欢恶作剧和开玩笑，虽然标准不像我们在节目中习惯的彼得大帝、强人奥古斯都或查理十二世的标准那样。是的，但问题是，我认为他们的恶作剧相当具有威胁性。你可不想卷入诸如风箱、熊或类似的东西里去。不，那不是闹着玩的。
But tell me what you think of this tasteful prank. So they were all out drinking with some friends like Theo with Paul Rouse in Dublin. One of their friends who was a doctor got absolutely wasted. And basically, when he passed out, they bundled him up to the country. They locked him in a farmhouse. And they went back to Florence and spread a rumor that he was dead. And when he escaped and went home, his wife shrieked, thought he was a ghost who wouldn't let him in. What do you think of that? I see. I think that's great.
但你觉得这个有品味的恶作剧怎么样？他们当时和一些朋友在都柏林喝酒，就像西奥和保罗·罗斯那样。他们其中一个当医生的朋友喝得酩酊大醉。基本上，等他昏迷不省人事后，他们把他打包带到了乡下。把他锁在一个农舍里。然后他们回到了佛罗伦萨，散布谣言说他已经死了。等他逃脱并回到家时，他妻子吓得尖叫，以为他是鬼魂，怎么也不肯让他进门。你觉得这个怎么样？我明白了。我觉得这太棒了。
Yeah, it's great banter. Well, I think it's very, very Renaissance Florence appropriate, because it's like a short story from Boccaccio or something. Yeah, it is exactly. It is. Whereas if they had kind of mated him with a bear or something like that, that would be inappropriate. I don't think we've ever had a moment of, of human bear relations
对，这真是太棒的玩笑话了。嗯，我觉得这非常、非常符合文艺复兴时期佛罗伦萨的特色，因为它就像薄伽丘或其他人的短篇小说一样。是的，它确实如此。它就是。而如果他们把他和一头熊配对或者做类似的事情，那就很不合适了。我想我们节目中从来没有出现过人与熊发生那种关系的时刻吧？有吗？对，但你知道的，我的意思是，这显然是事情发展的方向。
in that way on the show. Have we? Yeah, but you know, I mean, that's obviously where it's heading. Yeah. So I like that. I like that. Anyway, Lorenzo also liked Theo. He loves music. He loves songs and poems. I think this is unlike Theo. He dabbles in architectural
所以，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这样。不管怎样，洛伦佐也喜欢西奥。他热爱音乐。他喜欢歌曲和诗歌。我认为这一点和西奥不同。他涉猎建筑
drawing, which I'm not aware as a youngsmith hobby. On the downside, actually very like Theo, he's really competitive. Whenever he loses at something, he has a massive tantrum. So I think that's a black mark. Yeah, that is like Theo, isn't it? But he loves a party. So the most famous is they had this massive tournament in the Piazza Santa Croce in 1469 to celebrate his betrothal to Clarice. It was the most glamorous tournament anyone could remember.
绘图，据我所知这不是扬·史密斯的爱好。在缺点方面，其实和西奥非常像，他争强好胜得厉害。每当他在什么事情上输了，他就会大发雷霆。所以我觉得这是一个污点。是的，这确实很像西奥，对吧？但他喜欢聚会。所以最著名的一次是，他们在1469年在圣十字广场举办了一场盛大的比武大会，来庆祝他和克拉丽切的订婚。这是任何人能记忆中最为奢华的比武大会。
It cost 10,000 ducats. They all had these fancy helmets. He was wearing a white scarlet and silk cape, a velvet surcoat, a silk scarf embroidered with roses and a black velvet cap and he wore a helmet with three tall blue feathers. I mean that is not Theo. He looked very camp I would think. Theo does not dress in a camp manner.
它花费了1万达卡。他们都戴着这些华丽的头盔。他穿着一件白色、猩红色的丝绸披风、一件天鹅绒短上衣、一条绣着玫瑰花的丝绸围巾和一顶黑色天鹅绒帽子，还戴着一顶插着三根高高蓝色羽毛的头盔。我的意思是，这可不是西奥。我觉得他看起来非常妖艳。西奥可不会以妖艳的方式着装。
No, but he was declared the winner. He was actually not very good at fighting, but he was declared the winner anyway, basically because he bought the title. And then they have the wedding, which is a gigantic blowout. Remember we did that episode with John Dickey about Italian food. Yes. Mad Italian food. Yeah, all kinds of weird combinations.
不，但他被宣布为获胜者。其实他并不擅长战斗，但不管怎样他还是被宣布为获胜者，基本上是因为他买下了这个头衔。然后他们举行了婚礼，那是一场规模空前的狂欢。还记得我们和约翰·迪基做过的那期关于意大利食物的节目吗？是的。疯狂的意大利食物。对，各种奇怪的组合。
Right. So it's been like calf's liver stuffed with marzipan, a jelly made of a goose, all this kind of like weird sugared lamb or something like that. They have all this. That's what they're having at this. Yeah. 300 barrels of wine. However, there is a bad omen.
没错。比如塞满杏仁膏的小牛肝、由鹅肉做成的肉冻，所有这些奇奇怪怪的加糖羊肉之类的东西。他们吃的就是这些。这就是他们在婚礼上吃的。是的。300桶葡萄酒。然而，有一个不祥之兆。
It rains so heavily on the wedding morning that everybody gets completely soaked and all their lovely dresses are ruined. What about Lorenzo's feathers droopy? Probably drooping, disconsolate. Could this be an omen of disaster? Maybe. Because Piero the gout is health a few weeks afterwards takes a turn for the worse. And on the 2nd of December, 1469, Piero
婚礼那天早上下了那么大的雨，以至于每个人都彻底湿透了，他们所有漂亮的礼服全毁了。洛伦佐的羽毛呢？是不是垂头丧气的？可能垂头丧气的，闷闷不乐。这会是灾难的预兆吗？也许吧。因为痛风者皮耶罗的健康状况在几周后急转直下。1469年12月2日，皮耶罗
dies at his country villa in the hills above Florence. So he's done a solid job, Piero. He's only been there four and a half years, but he's weathered the kind of a bit of protest. He's strengthened the family's links with Milan and with Naples. But the question is, what will happen to the Medici bank and the Medici network now? Because I would say he's done more than a solid job. Because what effectively he's done is to establish the idea of heredity in the context of a republic. That's pretty impressive, I think. I agree with you. and the proof of that is what happens next So the night before Pierrot's funeral the Medici loyalists hold a meeting at the convent of Sant'Antonio And it's a very godfather scene
在佛罗伦萨群山之中的乡间别墅去世了。所以皮耶罗干得很出色。他只掌权了四年半，但他经受住了小规模的抗议。他加强了家族与米兰和那不勒斯的联系。但问题是，美第奇银行和美第奇网络现在会发生什么？因为我要说的是，他做的不只是出色。因为他实际上所做的是，在共和国的背景下确立了世袭的概念。我认为这相当了不起。我同意你的看法。而这的证明就是接下来发生的事情。所以在皮耶罗葬礼的前一晚，美第奇的忠实支持者在圣安东尼奥修道院举行了一次会议。这是一个非常具有教父风格的场景。
Because they all gather and the chief voice is this elderly Medici crony called Tommaso Sodorini, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy Sodorini is gonna give his verdict He's an old associate of Cosmos and he says, give the boy his chance. That's so good. And everybody kind of agrees and they say to Lorenzo, will you take on the care of the state? And he says, oh, I'm very reluctant. I would hate to do it. But obviously he's gagging to do it. He says he'll do it. And he wrote later on, he said, I did it solely to protect my friends and possessions, put fairs ill in Florence for anyone who is rich and does not
因为他们都聚集在一起，主要的发言者是这位年长的美第奇心腹，名叫托马索·索多里尼。汤米，汤米，汤米·索多里尼要发表他的裁决了。他是科西莫的老同伴，他说，给这个年轻人一个机会吧。这太棒了。大家都表示赞同，他们对洛伦佐说，你愿意承担起治理国家的责任吗？他说，哦，我很勉强。我实在不愿意这么做。但显然他内心渴望得要命。他说他会这么做。他后来写道，他说，我这么做纯粹是为了保护我的朋友和财产，在佛罗伦萨，对于任何富有却不
control the state. I mean, that's such a telling phrase, isn't it? Yeah. So it might be an element of truth in that you're targets. And if you're not in charge, they will come for you. You'll be brought down. You'll be brought down. Now he's already written to the Duke of Milan to secure his support.
掌控国家的人来说，日子都不好过。我的意思是，这是一句多么意味深长的话，不是吗？是的。所以其中可能包含着一部分真相，那就是你会成为靶子。如果你不掌权，他们就会来找你。你会被扳倒的。你会被扳倒的。现在他已经写信给米兰公爵以争取他的支持。
That gives him the muscle that he needs. And so at the age of not yet 21, Lorenzo de' Medici assumes control of the bank, of the family, and of the fortunes of Florence. But Tom, in the shadows, the knives are glinting. Oh my goodness, Dominic. And if the knives are glinting. Oh my goodness, Dominic. And if the knives are glinting, then that suggests that after the break, conspirators will be striking.
这给了他所需要的武力后盾。因此，在尚未满21岁的时候，洛伦佐·德·美第奇接管了银行、家族以及佛罗伦萨的命运。但是Tom，在阴影之中，刀光闪烁。哦，天哪，多米尼克。如果刀光闪烁。哦，天哪，多米尼克。如果刀光闪烁，那就意味着中场休息过后，阴谋家们就要动手了。
But which conspirators and who will they be striking at? We will find out after the break. Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Condition Supply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details. Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist.
但究竟是哪些阴谋家？他们的目标又是谁？我们中场休息后揭晓。无论您是与家人、朋友还是毛茸茸的同伴一同踏上夏日的公路旅行，都可以尽情享受沃尔沃传奇安全性能带来的安心感。在沃尔沃探索日（Volvo Discover Days）期间，当您计划穿梭于穆斯科卡或多伦多繁华的街道时，即可享受限时优惠。从现在到6月30日，租赁2025款沃尔沃XC60，利率低至1.74%，最高可省4000加元。条款适用。请访问您身边的GTA沃尔沃零售商，或访问 volvocars.ca 了解完整详情。你好，我是戈登·卡雷拉，国家安全记者。
And I'm David McCloskey, CIA Analyst, Turnspy novelist. Together we're the co-hosts of another Goldhanger show called The Rest is Classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of secrets and spies. We have just released a series on the decades-long battle between the CIA and Osama Bin Laden and this week we are stepping into the devastation of the 9-11 terror attacks to understand how Osama Bin Laden was able to carry out such a plot right under the nose of the CIA. It was a moment that changed global politics forever, shifting the focus of spy agencies away from nation states
我是大卫·麦克洛斯基，CIA分析师、间谍小说家。我们共同主持另一个“金挂钩”节目《秘闻留存》（The Rest is Classified），在这里我们将为您带来来自秘密与间谍世界的最佳故事。我们刚刚发布了一个关于美国中情局与奥萨马·本·拉登之间长达数十年的斗争的系列节目，本周我们将走进“9·11”恐怖袭击事件的满目疮痍，去了解奥萨马·本·拉登是如何能够在CIA眼皮底下实施这样一场阴谋的。这是一个永远改变全球政治的时刻，它将间谍机构的焦点从民族国家
towards hunting for terrorists and understanding the extremist ideology that drove them. We will then go into the decade-long manhunt for Osama bin Laden, which culminated in a dramatic raid at his compound in Pakistan in 2011, which killed the world's most wanted terrorist. So if all of this sounds good, we've got a clip waiting for you at the end of the episode. Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History and Dominic, it is December 1469 and Lorenzo
转移到了搜寻恐怖分子以及理解驱动他们的极端主义意识形态上。随后，我们将深入探讨针对奥萨马·本·拉登长达十年的搜捕行动，该行动在2011年对他在巴基斯坦的宅邸的戏剧性突袭中达到高潮，击毙了全球最通缉的恐怖分子。如果这一切听起来不错，我们在节目末尾为您准备了一个片段。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，多米尼克，现在是1469年12月，洛伦佐
de' Medici, only 20 years old, has become head of the Medici family and therefore the master of Florence. But I suppose the huge question is, you know, is he up to it? Well, Cosimo and Piero were much older and more experienced when they took power. They were famously cautious and more experienced when they took power. They were famously cautious and calculating. Everybody says about Lorenzo, he's inexperienced, but he's also impulsive. He has absolutely no interest in banking. And this is a problem and it will become a bigger problem for his successors. But basically, they've inherited a family business in which
·德·美第奇年仅20岁，便已成为美第奇家族的族长，因而也是佛罗伦萨的主人。但我想最大的问题是，你知道，他能胜任吗？嗯，科西莫和皮耶罗在掌权时要年长得多，也更有经验。他们以谨慎和计算著称。而每个人对洛伦佐的评价都是他缺乏经验，但他同时又很冲动。他对银行业完全没有兴趣。这是一个问题，而且对他的继任者来说这将成为一个更大的问题。但基本上，他们继承了一个家族企业，
they are no longer terribly interested. He's good at writing poetry, he's good at playing football, he's good at playing music and playing pranks, but he's never actually run anything. And in the long run, as we will see, this is a problem for him and for the Medici family. And this is again, is a kind of classic business story, isn't it? Of course it is. Yeah, absolutely it is. The grandfather, the father, very calculating, and then the son who kind of blows it all, you know, has an expensive education and can't be bothered with what's actually made the money.
而他们对这个企业已经不再有那么大的兴趣了。他擅长写诗，擅长踢足球，擅长玩音乐和恶作剧，但他从没真正管理过任何事情。从长远来看，正如我们将看到的，这对他的美第奇家族来说是个问题。这又是一个典型的商业故事，不是吗？当然是的。是的，绝对是的。祖父、父亲都极其精明，然后是把这一切挥霍一空的儿子，你知道的，接受了昂贵的教育，却懒得去理会那些真正赚到钱的业务。
And actually the tone is set right away. So right away there's a sort of a lot of feasting and dancing. I think there's a slightly camp side to Lorenzo as we discussed before. You've written Lorenzo's slightly camp hey nonny nonny way. Yeah, I think there's a lot of capering. Yeah. To a loot. Yeah, there's a lot of loot work and a lot of capering and laughing. A lot of tights. Yeah, laughing excessively at slightly amusing jokes. I think there's a lot of that. And there's all these horse races and mock battles. Lorenzo particularly enjoys a jake with an animal, which is a real theme of history as we've discovered on this podcast. So he turns the Piazza della Signoria into this sort of circus.
而且这种基调从一开始就定下了。所以一开始就有大量的宴会和舞蹈。正如我们之前讨论的那样，我认为洛伦佐身上有一种稍微带点妖艳的气质。你写过洛伦佐那种略带妖艳的“嗨，诺尼，诺尼”式的做派。是的，我觉得有很多蹦蹦跳跳。是的，伴随着鲁特琴。是的，有很多鲁特琴的弹奏以及蹦跳和大笑。有很多紧身裤。是的，对略带趣味的笑话发出过度的大笑。我想有很多这样的成分。还有所有的赛马和模拟战斗。洛伦佐特别喜欢与动物恶作剧，正如我们在本播客中所发现的，这是历史的一个真正主题。所以他把领主广场变成了一个马戏团。
So they'll have people attacking boars with lances, they'll try to stage fights between lions and dogs. And the weirdest one I think is basically they fill the square with stallions and then they set loose a mare in the square and the stallions all went absolutely berserk. And a diarist writing at the time said, and I quote, it was the most marvelous entertainment for girls to behold. Nice. So I don't know whether Tabby would agree with that. I mean, again, there's an obvious kind of slight Roman echo there.
于是他们会让人们用长矛攻击野猪，他们会试图安排狮子和狗之间的战斗。我想最奇怪的一场是，基本上他们在广场上挤满了种马，然后把一匹母马放进广场，所有的种马都彻底狂乱了。当时的一位日记作家写道，我引述一下，“对于少女们来说，这是最奇妙的娱乐观赏。”太好了。所以，我不知道塔比是否会同意这一点。我的意思是，这同样有一种明显的、轻微的罗马回响。
Oh, definitely. The pillar work in Florence that is going into the Medici palace and so on. It is drawn from the Coliseum. Yeah. And the Coliseum obviously serves no purpose because they're not staging beast fights, but it's obviously on the Medici radar. So perhaps there's something like that going on. I think so.
绝对是的。佛罗伦萨那些融入美第奇宫等的柱廊。它是从斗兽场汲取灵感的。是的。而且斗兽场显然没有起到什么作用，因为他们并不是在上演野兽搏斗，但它显然在美第奇家族的雷达范围内。所以也许正在发生类似的事情。我想是的。
And again, just to flag up what I think is the single most exciting event in the whole story of the Medici is the arrival of a giraffe. But I think that's in the next episode, isn't it? I think that's in the next episode. But that's coming. So that's also part of this Roman style obsession with animals and things. If you're a member of the Rested Sister Club and you're into giraffes, you can skip the rest of this episode about the conspiracy.
再次重申，我认为美第奇家族整个故事中最令人兴奋的单件大事件就是一头长颈鹿的到来。但我认为那是在下一期节目里，对吧？我想那是在下一集。但那就要来了。所以这也是这种罗马式对动物和事物的痴迷的一部分。如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员并且你对长颈鹿感兴趣，你可以跳过这集关于阴谋的其余部分。
Go straight to the giraffe. But most people obviously should listen to this episode first. So why is Lorenzo so extravagant? I think because unlike his father and his grandfather, he is desperate to be considered a prince. Now his nickname, Il Magnifico, the Magnificent, we think that's because he was so great. He was so glorious. No, that is wrong.
直接去看长颈鹿。但大多数人显然应该先听这一集。那么，为什么洛伦佐如此奢侈？我想因为不像他的父亲和祖父，他极其渴望被当成一位亲王。现在他的绰号，Il Magnifico，即“伟大者”，我们以为那是因为他太伟大了。他太辉煌了。不，那是错的。
It is a standard honorific that was given to rich merchants and to the heads of families. Right. So he's not a principae. No. So every time he is called ill magnifico, that is a reminder of his sort of subordinate status. He's silver class, not gold class. Exactly. Exactly.
这是一个标准尊称，通常给予富有的商人和家族领袖。对。所以他不是统治者（principae）。不。所以每次他被称为“ill magnifico”（伟大者）时，这都是在提醒他那种从属的地位。他是白银阶层，而不是黄金阶层。完全正确。完全正确。
And here's the thing. This is the big difference between him and his father and grandfather. They lent money. He borrows it. He trades on the bank's reputation to start borrowing money to fund his lifestyle. So he borrowed 61,000 Florins from his cousin. He borrowed 10,000 Florins from the Duke of Milan. And remember, the whole thing with the alliance with Milan was that the Medici Bank was bankrolling Milan. Now it's the other way around. He's borrowing money. Now he said later on, you know, I don't regret it. I think the money was well spent and I'm well pleased. But more caustic historians of the Medici
而且事情是这样的。这就是他和他的父亲与祖父之间的巨大区别。他们借出钱。他借入钱。他利用银行的声誉开始借钱来资助他的生活方式。所以他向他的表弟借了61,000弗林金币。他向米兰公爵借了10,000弗林金币。记住，与米兰结盟的全部意义在于美第奇银行在为米兰提供资金支持。现在情况反过来了。他在借钱。现在他后来曾说，你知道，我不后悔。我认为钱花得很值，我对此很满意。但美第奇家族更尖酸刻薄的历史学家，比如玛丽·霍林斯沃思在她的书中说，这就是腐败开始的时候。我的意思是，她基本上把他描绘成
family like Mary Hollingsworth in her book say this is when the rot started. I mean, she basically paints him. It's a great book, actually, her book. She paints him as this arrogant, spoiled, super rich kid who blew his inheritance. She says, quote, a depressing tale of greed and inexperience from which the Medici brand never really recovered. Just to present the counter argument, I mean, the fact that he is still thought of as the embodiment of Renaissance prints right up to the present day, and the fact that, spoiler alert, the Medici in due course will establish themselves as the Dukes of Florence. Surely that suggests that to a degree
一个傲慢、被宠坏、超级富有的富二代，挥霍了他的遗产。她说，引述一下，“这是一个关于贪婪和缺乏经验的令人沮丧的故事，美第奇品牌从此再也没有真正恢复过。”为了提出反驳的论点，我的意思是，事实上他直到今天仍然被认为是文艺复兴时期亲王的化身，而且——剧透一下——美第奇家族在适的时候将确立自己作为佛罗伦萨公爵的地位。这难道不表明，在某种程度上，
he's right in saying that by presenting himself as a princely figure, he's able to elevate his descendants to the actual rank of princes. Possibly, although there are an awful lot of twists and turns before we get to that point. I mean, there are a couple of generations, there are periods of exile and whatnot. I mean, you could argue that in the long run would have been better for them to be remained in the shadows and piled up the money. That's what I would have done, Tom.
他说得对：通过把自己塑造成一个有王者风范的人物，他能够将自己的后代提升到真正的亲王阶层？可能吧，尽管在我们到达那个节点之前，还有相当多的曲折。我的意思是，有几代人，有流放的时期等等。我的意思是，你可以争辩说，从长远来看，让他们保持低调并积累财富可能会更好。Tom，我要是他就这么干了。
I don't need a fancy helmet, you know, with feathers on it. I'd rather have the money. This is perhaps where you and I differ. All I will say is that we're going to be doing a series on Mary Queen of Scots. Edamidechi will be featuring in that story as a Queen of France. So they did do well in the end. They do do well. Now some listeners may be a bit surprised to hear anybody criticizing Lorenzo because
我不需要一个镶着羽毛的华丽头盔，你知道的。我宁愿要钱。这也许就是你和我意见相左的地方。我要说的是，我们将要做一个关于苏格兰女王玛丽的系列节目。艾达·美第奇将在那个故事中以法兰西王后的身份登场。所以他们最终还是干得不错的。他们确实干得不错。现在，有些听众听到有人批评洛伦佐可能会感到有些惊讶
basically as in the Assassin's Creed video game he's usually treated as thoroughly admirable but of course you're not thoroughly admirable if you're wielding power in Renaissance Italy. You know, a saint doesn't wield such power. And his chief ally, I mean, it's a really good example of this. His chief ally is the Duke of Milan, Gagliazzo Maria Sforza. He's a patron of the arts, he's a complete Renaissance man, but he's also a complete psycho. Is this the son of the guy who was bending iron bars in the previous episode? It is his son, Francesco's son, and Galeazzo Maria Sforzi. He's a pungent character, I think it's fair to say, Tom.
基本上，就像在《刺客信条》电子游戏里一样，他通常被认为是个完全令人钦佩的人，但当然，如果你在文艺复兴时期的意大利手握权力，你就不会是个完全令人钦佩的人。你知道的，圣人是不会掌握这种权力的。而他的主要盟友——我的意思是，这是一个非常好的例子。他的主要盟友是米兰公爵加莱亚佐·玛丽亚·斯福尔扎。他是艺术的赞助者，是一个地道的文艺复兴人，但他也是一个彻底的疯子。这是上一集里那个能弯曲铁条的那家伙的儿子吗？正是他的儿子，弗朗切斯科的儿子，加莱亚佐·玛丽亚·斯福尔扎。我觉得公平地说，托姆，他是一个性格极其鲜明的人。
Do you want to know what he got up to? Yeah, I'd love to. I quote, he raped the wives and daughters of numerous Milanese nobles. He took sadistic pleasure in devising tortures for men who offended him. He supervised these tortures himself and pulled their limbs apart with his own bare hands. And he delighted in the moans of dying men in the sight of corpses." So this is very much the English Renaissance sense of what Italian princes are getting up to, isn't it?
你想知道他干过什么吗？是的，我很想听。我引述一下，“他强奸了无数米兰贵族的妻子和女儿。他以设计折磨那些冒犯他的人为虐待狂般的乐事。他亲自监督这些酷刑，并用自己的双手把他们的四肢扯断。他以垂死之人的呻吟和看到尸体为乐。”所以这非常符合英国文艺复兴时期对意大利王子们所作所为的看法，对吧？
Exactly, yeah. The black legend of the Italian Renaissance, if such a thing existed. And actually you may say, well, obviously this is exaggerating propaganda, but to be a Renaissance magnate you have to behave in pretty grim ways and Lorenzo himself is a good example. Remember we talked about that alum mine? Oh yes. So in 1472 Lorenzo becomes involved with another alum mine. This is in Volterra, just south of Florence. Now this is a town that is under Florentine control where the locals have discovered a load of alum and they've developed a mine. The problem for Lorenzo is that Volterra's alum is cheaper than the alum made by the Medici controlled mine near Rome. And so basically there's a big dispute
完全正确。意大利文艺复兴的黑色传奇，如果真有这种东西的话。事实上你可能会说，好吧，这显然是夸张的宣传，但要成为一个文艺复兴时期的巨头，你必须表现得相当冷酷，洛伦佐本人就是一个很好的例子。还记得我们谈过那个明矾矿吗？噢，是的。所以在1472年，洛伦佐卷入了另一个明矾矿。这在沃尔泰拉，就在佛罗伦萨的正南方。这是一个处于佛罗伦萨控制之下的城镇，那里的当地人发现了一堆明矾并开发了一个矿。对洛伦佐来说，问题在于沃尔泰拉的明矾比美第奇家族控制的罗马附近的明矾便宜。所以基本上产生了一场巨大的纠纷，
about control of the Volterra consortium. He uses Florentine troops to go in and teach Volterra a lesson and bring it into his orbit. And the Volterrans are completely helpless and the result is an unbridled massacre. Lorenzo's mercenaries run amok in Volterra. They rampage through the town for 12 hours. They loot all the shops. They kill hundreds of people. There is mass rape.
关于对沃尔泰拉财团的控制权。他动用佛罗伦萨军队前去给沃尔泰拉一个教训，将其纳入他的势力范围。而沃尔泰拉人完全束手无策，结果是一场毫无节制的屠杀。洛伦佐的雇佣兵在沃尔泰拉大开杀戒。他们在城里横行了12小时。他们洗劫了所有的店铺。他们杀害了数以百计的人。发生了大规模强奸。
It is a horrendous story. Now afterwards, Lorenzo says, oh, that's such a shame. I'm so sad that that went a little bit too far. I feel so guilty about it. But actually, I think even at the time, people thought this is very disingenuous of him. He basically unleashed his mercenaries on this town for his own financial gain. And also to enhance his reputation as a man, it's dangerous to cross. I assume. Right. But the problem with doing that is that if there are other powerful people,
这是一个骇人听闻的故事。事后，洛伦佐说，哦，太遗憾了。我很难过事情做得有点过头了。我为此感到非常内疚。但事实上，我认为即使在当时，人们也认为他非常虚伪。他基本上为了自己的经济利益，把雇佣兵放到了这个城镇。同时也是为了提升他作为那种惹不起的狠角色的声誉。我猜是这样的。没错。但这样做的问题在于，如果还有其他有权有势的人，
they may say you've crossed a line and now we're going to move against you. And there are other powerful people in Florence because the Medici are not the only powerful banking family. There is another family called the Pazzi. Now Patsy are an older and more prestigious family than the Medici. So one of their ancestors, Tom, this will appeal to you, had gone on the first crusade and he brought back some stone flints from the altar of the Holy Sepulcher. Oh, I'm definitely team Patsy. Right. Well, the Patsy trade on this. They bring them out, I think, every Easter and kind of parade around the city with them and people are weeping with joy and all this. I don't want to sound dismissive, but
他们可能会说你越界了，现在我们要对你采取行动了。佛罗伦萨还有其他有权有势的人，因为美第奇家族并不是唯一的强大银行家族。还有一个家族叫帕齐。帕齐家族是一个比美第奇家族更古老、更有声望的家族。所以他们的一个祖先，托姆，这会吸引你的，曾参加过第一次十字军东征，并从圣墓教堂的圣坛上带回了一些打火石。哦，我绝对是帕齐队的人。好吧，帕齐家族借此大作文章。我想他们每年复活节都会把这些东西拿出来，带着它们在城里游行，人们感动得痛哭流涕，诸如此类。我不想听起来显得不屑，但是
you know my views on Relics. The Pazzi have got a big banking network of their own. They've got offices in Florence and in Rome and in Avignon, Valencia and all these places. And the head of the Pazzi family is not like Lorenzo at all. He's called Jacopo de Pazzi. He's in his mid-50s. He's simultaneously, I think an interesting combination, he's both a miser and a gambler. He's very competitive. And you get this sense, I think maybe this is my sort of romantic imagination, that he is watching Lorenzo with the cold eyes of a predator all the time.
你知道我对圣物的看法。帕齐家族有他们自己的庞大银行网络。他们在佛罗伦萨、罗马、阿维尼翁、瓦伦西亚以及所有这些地方都有办事处。而帕齐家族的族长一点也不像洛伦佐。他叫雅科波·德·帕齐。他五十岁出头。我认为他有一种有趣的组合，他既是个守财奴又是个赌徒。他好胜心极强。你会有一种感觉，也许这是我某种浪漫的想象，他一直在用捕食者冰冷的目光注视着洛伦佐。
I like the sound of him. He's got relics. He's in his mid fifties, intensely competitive. He's like you. He's quite like me. Cold eyes of a predator. Cold eyes of a predator. Exactly.
我挺喜欢他的。他有圣物。他五十岁出头，好胜心极强。他就像你。他挺像我的。捕食者冰冷的目光。捕食者冰冷的目光。完全正确。
But let's see who this man reminds you of. There's another ruthless character who's watching Lorenzo very closely. And this is a man called Francesco del Rovere or rather Pope Sixtus IV. So Pope Sixtus IV came from a fishing town in Liguria. He's a bit of a self-made man. He has climbed the ecclesiastical ladder to win the papacy. He's very clever, but he's a complete bruiser. So Christopher Hibbett, who's very good at these pen portraits, calls him a big, gruff,
但让我们看看这个人让你想起了谁。还有另一个冷酷的角色正在密切注视着洛伦佐。这个人就是弗朗切斯科·德尔·罗维雷，或者更准确地说是教皇西克斯图斯四世。所以教皇西克斯图斯四世来自利古里亚的一个渔镇。他有点像是白手起家的人。他通过爬上教会的阶梯赢得了教皇之位。他非常聪明，但却是个十足的粗人。所以克里斯托弗·希贝特（Christopher Hibbett），非常擅长这种人物素描，称他为一个身材高大、粗鲁、
toothless man with a massive head, a small squashed nose and an intimidating expression. Goodness, I can't think who that reminds me of. I think he's a bit like the Emperor of Aspasian. A bit, yeah. Now, he's incredibly corrupt, even by papal standards. So that I can now bring out my inner Thomas Cromwell. He's handing out offices to his family.
没牙的男人，长着一个硕大的脑袋、一个扁塌的小鼻子和一张令人望而生畏的表情。天哪，我想不出这让我想起了谁。我觉得他有点像阿斯巴西奥皇帝。有点像，对。现在，他极其腐败，即使以教皇的标准来看也是如此。所以我现在可以释放我内心的托马斯·克伦威尔了。他把官职分发给自己的家族。
He makes six of his nephews cardinals. But if he genuinely thought that they were worthy of it, I don't see what the problem is. I'm sure he did think that. Yeah, I'm sure they're genuinely really kind of upstanding religious people. Now, at first, he confirmed the Medici as the papal bankers and he actually sent Lorenzo some presents. He sent him busts of Augustus and a gripper. No better present than that. Those choices are a sign of Lorenzo. Lorenzo is following in Cosimo's footsteps at this
他把他的六个侄子封为枢机主教。但如果他真心认为他们配得上这个称号，我不明白问题出在哪里。我确信他是这么认为的。是的，我确信他们真的都是那种正直的宗教人士。起初，他确认为第奇家族为教皇的银行家，实际上他还给洛伦佐送了一些礼物。他送给他奥古斯都和阿格里帕的半身像。没有比这更好的礼物了。这些选择是洛伦佐的一个标志。洛伦佐正是在这一点上步了科西莫的后尘，对吧？
point, right? Yeah. Cosimo admired Augustus, but then they have a massive falling out in 1473. Sixtus had a favorite nephew who he hadn't made to Cardinal yet called Girolamimo Riario, who is described as, and I quote, a fat uncouth rowdy young man. And everybody says this bloke Riario is actually the Pope's son. He's not really his nephew, he's his son. Riario wanted to buy the town of Imola.
是的。科西莫很崇拜奥古斯都，但后来他们在1473年彻底闹翻了。西克斯图斯有一个宠爱的侄子，他还没让他当上枢机主教，名叫吉罗拉莫·里里奥，被描述为——我引用一下——“一个肥胖、粗鲁、无礼的年轻人”。而且所有人都说这个叫里里奥的家伙实际上是教皇的儿子。他其实不是他的侄子，他是他的儿子。里里奥想买下伊莫拉镇。
He's a fan of Formula One. Formula One, exactly, has a key strategic location on the road from Bologna. And Sixtus said to the Medici bank, could you lend us the money, please, to buy this town of Imola? Now Lorenzo was horrified at this. He wanted Imola for Florence. There was no way he was gonna let it fall into somebody else's hands.
他是个一级方程式车迷。一级方程式，没错，它在通往博洛尼亚的道路上具有关键的战略位置。西克斯图斯对美第奇银行说，你们能借给我们钱买下伊莫拉这个镇吗？洛伦佐对此感到惊恐万状。他想要伊莫拉归佛罗伦萨所有。他绝不可能让它落入其他人手中。
And he turns down the loan. The Pope is furious. Who does the Pope turn to for the money? He turns to the Pazzi bank, and Jacopo gave him the money. A year later, in the summer of 1474, Sixtus got his revenge on the Medici. He stripped them of the papal account and gave it to the Pazzi. And then, as the new Archbishop of Pisa, which was in Florentine control, he appointed Jacopo
他拒绝了这笔贷款。教皇大发雷霆。教皇找谁借钱呢？他找了帕齐银行，雅科波把钱借给了他。一年后，即1474年夏天，西克斯图斯对美第奇家族进行了报复。他剥夺了他们的教皇账户，并交给了帕齐家族。然后，作为新任比萨总主教（该地受佛罗伦萨控制），他任命雅科波·德·帕齐的表弟弗朗切斯科·萨尔维亚蒂。还记得他吗，这个叫萨尔维亚蒂的家伙。洛伦佐显然对此感到非常冒犯。你可以看出这是一次巨大的冷落，帕齐家族正在受到重用。而洛伦佐，他这时候多大？他出生于1449年，所以他27岁，托姆，因为我们现在正接近1476年底。
de Pazzi's cousin, Francesco Salviati. Remember him, this bloke Salviati. Lorenzo was obviously very offended by this. You could see that this was a massive snub, that the Pazzi were being advanced. And Lorenzo, how old is he at this point? He's born in 1449, so he's 27, Tom, because we're now approaching the end of 1476.
现在，某种意义上事情正在对她不利。教皇已经背叛了他，然后在节礼日，他从米兰收到了可怕的消息。他的朋友，那个疯子加莱亚佐·玛丽亚·斯福尔扎，在去弥撒的路上被暗杀。而他的儿子只有七岁，米兰爆发了巨大的继承危机。所以米兰现在实际上已经出局了。洛伦佐最大的盟友。几周后，三个人在罗马秘密会面。其中一人是吉罗拉莫·里里奥。
Now, there's a sense in which things are turning against him. The Pope has turned against him, and then on Boxing Day, he gets terrible news from Milan. His friend Galeazzo Maria Sforza, the psycho, he has been assassinated on his way to mass. And his son is only seven and there's a massive succession crisis in Milan. So Milan is now effectively out of the game. Lorenzo's biggest ally. And a few weeks later, three men meet in secret in Rome. One of them is Girolamo Riario.
所以他就是那个肥胖、粗鲁的教皇侄子兼儿子。是的。其中一人是弗朗切斯科·萨尔维亚蒂，那个刚被任命为比萨总主教的帕齐表弟。另一个人是弗朗切斯科·帕齐，他是帕齐银行罗马分行的经理，被描述为——引述一下——“一个极其傲慢自大的年轻男子”。这三个人会面只讨论一件事，而且是一件唯一的事，那就是如何除掉洛伦佐·德·美第奇。
So he's the fat, rowdy, papal nephew stroke son. Yeah. One of them is Francesco Salviati, the Pazzi cousin who has just been made the Archbishop of Pisa. And the other man is Francesco de Pazzi and he is the manager of the Pazzi Bank in Rome and he is described as an quote a young man of great arrogance and pretension. And these three men have met to discuss one thing and one thing only and that is how to get rid of Lorenzo de Medici.
天哪，这太黑手党了，不是吗？所以他们开了这个会。不久之后，银行经理弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐——他基本上是这一切的主谋——要求与罗马最顽固的一位雇佣兵指挥官会面。这个人叫蒙泰塞科，多年来为教皇做过很多脏活。
God it's so mafia, isn't it? So they have this meeting. Soon after that, Francesco de' Pazzi, the bank manager, who's basically brains behind all this, he asks for a meeting with one of Rome's most hard-bitten mercenary commanders. And this is a man called Montesecco, who has done a lot of dirty work
弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐对他说：“我想雇你执行一次针对美第奇家族的行动。”而蒙泰塞科说：“没有教皇的批准，我什么都不会做。”弗朗切斯科说：“太好了，因为教皇已经同意了。”现在蒙泰塞科不相信他。于是他们安排与西克斯图斯四世本人会面。教皇说，他话说得很含蓄，他说：“显然我最不愿意见到的就是任何杀戮。
for the papacy over the years. And Francesco de Pazzi says to him, I would like to hire you for an operation against the Medici. And Montesecco says, I'm not going to do anything without the Pope's approval. And Francesco says, great, because the Pope is already on board. Now Montesecco doesn't believe him. So they organize a meeting with Sixtus IV himself. And the Pope says, he's quite elliptical, he says, obviously the last thing I would
上帝保佑。如果你杀了人，我会非常难过的。那太糟糕了。如果你杀了洛伦佐·德·美第奇。我其实讨厌流血，如果洛伦佐死了，我会非常非常难过。然而，我真的非常想摆脱洛伦佐。我非常强烈地渴望摆脱洛伦佐。我非常强烈地
like to see is any killing. Heaven for Fenn. It would make me really sad if you killed. That would be awful. If you killed Lorenzo de' Medici. I actually hate bloodshed and if Lorenzo was dead, I'd be very, very upset. However, I'd really like to see the back of Lorenzo. I really strongly desire to see the back of Lorenzo. I really strongly
渴望看到这种改变。我希望看到洛伦佐从佛罗伦萨的画面中消失。”显然蒙泰塞科领会了意图。洛伦佐必须死，而且可能并不太介意这一点。所以链条中只剩下一个环节，那就是家族族长雅科波·德·帕齐。但他是个冷静理智的人，不是吗？完全正确。现在，他是个银行家，他知道失败的代价。当雇佣兵蒙泰塞科去找他时，他说，我觉得这是一部烂片，他说，引述原话，
desire to see this change. I want to see Lorenzo disappear from the picture in Florence. And obviously Montesecco gets the message. Lorenzo has got to go and probably doesn't really mind that much. So there's only one link in the chain left and that is Jacopo de Pazzi, the head of the family. But he's a chill calculating man, isn't he? Exactly. Now, he's a banker and he knows the costs of failure. When Montesecco, the mercenary, goes to see him, he says, I think this is a bad movie, he says, quote,
“他们会自取灭亡的。我对这里发生的事情的理解比他们要透彻。我不想再听到任何关于这件事的事了。”但蒙泰塞科说：“听着，教皇已经加入进来了。我们有钱，我们有武力，我们能做到。”雅科波说：“你知道的，这太像《教父2》了。”他说：“好吧，干吧。但你不能只杀洛伦佐。你必须杀掉他的兄弟朱利亚诺，而且你们必须同时动手。你知道的，不能出差错。我们必须把这件事做好。”
they're going to break their necks. I understand what is going on here better than they do. I don't want to hear any more about this. But Montesecco says, look, the pope is on board with this. We've got the money, we've got the muscle, we can do it. And Jacopo says, you know, it's so Godfather Part 2. He says, fine, do it. But you can't just kill Lorenzo. You must kill his brother, Giuliano, and you must do it at the same time. You know, no slip ups. We have to get this right.
因为上一集的经验教训是，如果你要打击美第奇家族，你就必须把他们斩草除根。完全正确。于是他们在协商这一切的同时，几个月过去了。终于到了1478年初。他们尝试过各种不同的计划，但现在他们有了自认为绝佳的机会。教皇的另一个亲戚，一个名叫拉斐尔·里里奥的年轻枢机主教，要去
Because the lesson from the previous episode is that if you're striking at the Medici, you've got to get rid of all of them. Exactly. So the months pass while they're negotiating all this. And finally we get to early 1478. They've toyed with various different schemes, but now they have what they think is the right opportunity. Another relative of the Pope, who's a young Cardinal called Raffaele Riario, is going
访问佛罗伦萨，完全无关的访问。洛伦佐为他组织了一场宴会。他们心想，对，宴会就是动手的时机。他们制定了计划，蒙泰塞科基本上把他的雇佣兵连队驻扎在佛罗伦萨郊外的村庄里，准备在关键时刻涌入城市。但随后他们听到坏消息。兄弟朱利亚诺眼睛感染了，可能不会去参加宴会。所以他们毕竟不能在那里动手了。
to visit Florence, completely unrelated. And Lorenzo has organized a banquet for him. And they're like, right, the banquet is the time to strike. They make their plans and Montesecco basically stations his mercenary company in the villages outside Florence, ready to pour into the city at the crucial moment. But then they hear bad news. Giuliano, the brother, has an eye infection and he's probably not going to go to the banquet. So they can't do it there after all.
他们匆忙开会讨论局势。他们说，听着，我们已经告诉了这么多人，消息正在泄露。蒙泰塞科已经把他的部下带到了托斯卡纳，现在真的是千钧一发了。然后其中一个人说，看，其实还有一个可能。在4月26日星期日，美第奇兄弟势必会和这位年轻的枢机主教维里奥一起去大教堂做大弥撒。这就是机会。这是兄弟俩必然会聚在一起的唯一地方。我们为什么不在那里动手呢？计划是在圣坛前的弥撒上砍死他们。是的。在一个教堂里。是的。在所有人面前。所有聚集的神职人员面前。教皇会对此作何反应？
They meet hurriedly to discuss the position. They say, look, we've told so many people now, word is leaking out. Montesecco has brought his men to Tuscany, like it's really now or never. And then one of them says, look, there is actually one more possibility. On Sunday the 26th of April, the Medici brothers are bound to go to high mass in the cathedral with this young Cardinal Viario. This is the chance. This is the one place where the brothers are bound to be together. Why don't we strike there? The plan is to cut them down at mass in front of the altar. Yeah. In a church. Yeah. In front of everybody. All the assembled clergy. How would the Pope react to this?
我们会找到答案的。我想教皇会接受的。我的意思是，托姆，他们在哪里动手，上帝都在看着。老实说，在哪里发生对上帝来说没有任何区别。我认为在哪里发生对上帝是有区别的。我不认为上帝会赞成人们在教堂圣坛前被谋杀。但你觉得如果是公共厕所之类的，上帝就觉得没问题？好吧，去吧。这是一个有趣的神学问题，但我只是普遍认为在教堂的大弥撒上谋杀人们可能不是你不会赞同。不是我赞不赞同，是上帝赞不赞同。我只是觉得上帝不会赞同那种事。在这方面你可真是冒了神学的险。
We'll find out. I think the Pope will live with it. I mean, God's watching wherever they do it, Tom. Let's be honest. It doesn't make any difference to God where it happens. I think it does make a difference to God where it happens I don't think God would at all approve of people being murdered in front of the altar of the church But you think God would be right with it was like a public toilet or something fine. Yeah crack on It's an interesting theological question, but I just generally think murdering people in cathedrals at high mass is probably not you don't approve it Not whether I approve it, whether God approves it. I just don't think God would approve of that. Going out on a theological limb there.
好吧。我们来过一遍计划的细节。所以弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐，那个年轻傲慢的银行经理，他将杀死朱利亚诺，他将得到一个名叫巴伦切利的冒险家的帮助，后者欠了帕齐家族很多钱，基本上想借此一笔勾销债务。这就是他们对付朱利亚诺的方式。至于洛伦佐，身经百战的雇佣兵队长蒙泰塞科将杀死他。但实际上蒙泰塞科就像你一样。
Okay. Let's talk through the details of the plan. So Francesco de Pazzi, the young, arrogant bank manager, he will kill Giuliano and he will be helped by an adventurer called Baroncelli who owes the Pazzi lots of money and wants to basically wipe away the debt. So that's how they deal with Giuliano. Now Lorenzo, the hard-bitten mercenary captain Montesecco will kill him. But actually Montesecco is like you.
他对在教堂里干这事感到极度恐慌。他说：“我做不到。”实际上他明确表示：“我做不到，因为上帝会看到的。”所以他同意我的看法，上帝在公共厕所里看不到，但在大教堂里就能看到。我认为他不是那个意思，多米尼克。但手头还有其他两个候选人，这是个好消息。他们是——我引用一下——“瘦削而痛苦的牧师”。
He's in a terrible funk about doing this in the cathedral. He says, I can't do it. And actually he says explicitly, I can't do it because God will see it. So he agrees with me, God wouldn't see it in a public toilet, but he would see it at the cathedral. I don't think that's what he's saying, Dominic. But there are two other candidates on hand, which is good news. And these are, and I quote, lean, embittered priests.
最好的那种牧师。最好那种牧师，也是最好那种瘦削痛苦的人。他们叫巴尼奥尼和马菲。所以我们一开始提到的人，那个来自《刺客信条2》的人。巴尼奥尼是帕齐的家庭教师。马菲是那个人，他来自沃尔泰拉，那个有明矾矿的地方。是的，他们全城都被屠杀的地方。他恨洛伦佐对他的城镇做的事，这就是他们商定的信号：当圣器室的钟声响起时，在仪式上神父在圣餐前举起圣饼的那一刻。这真是越来越亵渎神明了。
The best kind. The best kind of priests and the best kind of lean and bittered people. And these are called Bagnoni and Mafei. So the person we began with, the person from Assassin's Creed 2. Banyoni is a Pazzi tutor. Maffei is the thing, he is from Volterra, the place with the Alamein. Yeah, where they've all been massacred. He hates Lorenzo for what he did to his town and this is what they agree the signal will be when the sacristy bell rings at the point in the service where the priest elevates the host before communion. This is just getting more and more sacrilegious.
哦，这太妙了，所以这是一个绝对不能错过的信号。至关重要的是，在那一刻，当钟声响起时，包括美第奇兄弟在内的整个会众都会虔诚地低下头。所以他们将在那时杀死他们，然后那个比萨总主教萨尔维亚蒂。他将带着武装雇佣兵占领西诺利亚宫。他将把佛罗伦萨政府官员扣为人质，粉碎抵抗，帕齐家族将控制这座城市。这真是个绝妙的计划。
Oh it's brilliant so this is an unmissable signal and crucially at that moment when the bell rings the whole congregation including the Medici brothers will have bowed their heads in reverence. So they'll kill them then and then the bloke is the Archbishop of Pisa, Salviati. He will seize the Palazzo della Signore with the armed mercenaries. He'll take the Florentine government prisoner, he'll crush resistance and the pazzi will control the city. It's a great plan.
我的意思是，这可不是大主教该有的行为。确实不是，但这真是一个有趣的计划。我想是的。我想这就是它的天才之处。这是你从一个大主教身上最意想不到的事。完全正确。如果是一个大主教和两个满腹怨气的神父。太棒了。谁能想到呢？所以我们迎来了1478年4月26日星期日的早晨。大约11点，洛伦佐带着他的客人里里奥枢机主教从美第奇宫出发了。
I mean, this is not good archepiscopal behavior. It's not, but it is a fun plan. I suppose it is. I suppose that's the genius of it. It's the last thing they would expect from an archbishop. Exactly. If an archbishop and two embittered priests. Brilliant. Who'd have thought it? So we get to the morning of Sunday the 26th of April 1478. About 11 o'clock, Lorenzo sets off from the Medici Palace with his guest, Cardinal Riario.
他们实际上只花了——我已经在谷歌地图上查过了——他们从宫殿步行到大教堂只需要三分钟。那个阴险的萨尔维亚蒂大主教也中途加入了他们的步行。当他们到达大教堂时，大主教说：“哦，我其实得翘掉弥撒，因为我母亲身体不舒服。所以我把你们留在这儿。”天哪，他不仅要在举起圣饼时发动屠杀，而且他在撒谎。是的，这太卑鄙了，不是吗？难道他的罪恶没有极限吗？
It literally takes them, I've actually checked it on Google Maps, it takes them three minutes to walk from the palazzo to the Duomo. And they're joined on the walk by Archbishop Salviati, the snake. And when they get to the cathedral, the Archbishop says, oh, I actually have to skip Mass because my mother is feeling ill. So I'll leave you here. God, so not only is he going to launch a massacre as the host is being raised, but he's lying. Yeah, that's poor, isn't it? Is there no limit to his iniquity?
于是洛伦佐和枢机主教一起走进大教堂，他们走到主祭坛前，然后洛伦佐离开枢机主教，他们走到主祭坛前，然后洛伦佐离开枢机主教，去和一些朋友聊天，也就是一些美第奇的心腹。现在，对人们来说很重要的一点是想象一下，你是不坐下的，大教堂里没有椅子，没有长椅，人们都是站着的，他们三五成群地站着聊天、社交、走动，他们在仪式期间就会这样做。然而，朱利亚诺还没有到。
So Lorenzo goes into the cathedral with the cardinal, they go to the high altar, and then Lorenzo leaves the cardinal, they go to the high altar, and then Lorenzo leaves the cardinal and goes off to chat to some friends, some sort of Medici cronies. Now, important for people to picture this, you don't sit down, there are no chairs in the cathedral, no pews, people are standing and they're standing in groups, chatting and mingling and moving about, which they would do during the service. Giuliano, however, has not arrived.
他在哪儿？弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐和冒险家巴伦切利，他们去美第奇宫把他接来。这很像尤利乌斯·恺撒在他被谋杀的那天没有去元老院一样。完全正确。我的意思是，他们在文艺复兴时期显然有点在进行古典角色扮演，但这种节奏和韵律，看着挺有意思的。朱利亚诺感觉身体不舒服，其实他本想翘掉弥撒，但他们说服了他——又是一个非常尤利乌斯·恺撒式的举动——让他改变了主意。他们说：“来吧，会很有意思的。”于是他们陪他一起走向大教堂。一路上，我太喜欢这个细节了，
Where is he? Francesco de Pazzi and the adventurer Baroncelli, they go to the Palazzo Medici to fetch him. It's quite like Julius Caesar not going to the Senate House on the day he's murdered. Exactly. I mean, obviously they are kind of classical cosplaying in the Renaissance, but the kind of the rhythms and rhymes, it's nice to see. Giuliano is feeling ill and he was actually thinking about skipping mass, but they persuade him, again, very Julius Caesar, to change his mind. They say, come on, it'll be great fun. And so they walk with him to the cathedral. Along the way, I love this detail,
弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐搂住他的肩膀，捏了捏他说：“你胖了。”但实际上，弗朗切斯科这样做的原因是为了检查他衣服底下有没有穿盔甲，他欣慰地发现并没有。他们现在走进了大教堂。正午已到。仪式即将开始。朱利亚诺在唱诗班的一侧，即北侧，他的刺客们就站在四周。
Francesco de Pazzi puts his arm around him and gives him a squeeze and says, you're getting fat. But actually, the reason Francesco does that is to check if he's wearing armor under his clothes and he's relieved to find that he isn't. So they're now into the cathedral. It's midday. The service is about to start. Giuliano is on one side of the choir, the north side with his assassins standing around it.
洛伦佐在祭坛另一侧的走廊里，不管那叫什么。我甚至不知道那是什么。某种大教堂里的东西。他的许多朋友都在附近，但那两个杀手神父，那些消瘦的凶手就站在他身后不远。仪式开始了，你知道的，很多吟诵，无论我们进行到哪一步。我们达到了关键时刻，对吧？祭坛前的神父举起圣饼，
Lorenzo is on the other side of the altars in the ambulatory, whatever that is. I don't even know what it is. Some cathedral thing. There's lots of his friends nearby, but the two killer priests, the lean murderers were standing right, right behind him. The service starts, you know, a lot of chanting, whatever we reach. We reached the crucial moments, right? The priest of the altar lifts up the host
会众低下头，钟声响起。神父们拔出匕首。那个来自沃尔泰拉的家伙马菲，把手轻轻放在洛伦佐的肩膀上，仿佛在为突刺稳住身形。就在那一刻，洛伦佐转过身，他感觉到了脖子上的匕首，就在马菲猛刺进去的那一刻，他躲开了，所以
and the congregation bow their heads and the bell rings. And the priests draw their daggers. And the guy from Volterra, Maffei, he puts his hand gently on Lorenzo's shoulder, sort of to steady himself for the thrust. And Lorenzo turns at that point and he feels the dagger on his neck and just at the point when Murphy is digging it in he pulls away so what
结果是匕首划破了他的脖子，但没有杀死他。于是鲜血喷涌而出。血！洛伦佐脱下斗篷，把它缠在手臂上，把它当成盾牌来抵挡攻击，然后他伸手去拿他的抵挡攻击。然后他伸手去拿他的剑。他随身带了一把剑。他伸手去拿剑。他拔出剑。他向神父们砍去，然后他转身逃跑，跳过祭坛的栏杆，接着冲向圣器室的铜门，这可能会提供一些
happens is the dagger slices into his neck but it doesn't kill him. So there's a spurting of blood. Blood! Lorenzo pulls off his cloak he wraps it around his arm and he uses it as a shield kind of ward off the blows then he reaches for his ward off the blows. Then he reaches for his sword. He's carrying a sword. He reaches for his sword. He unsheathes it. He slashes at the priests and then he turns and he runs and he leaps over the rail of the altar and then he sprints for the bronze doors of the sacristy, which might offer some
庇护。因为怀特韦（Dwightway）有很多铜门，对吧？佛罗伦萨人极其喜爱铜门。与此同时，朱利亚诺发生了什么事？当钟声响起时，朱利亚诺像洛伦佐一样低下了头，他那一边的家伙们效率高得多。冒险家巴伦切利率先动手。他大喊：“接招吧，你这个叛徒！”
refuge. Because there are a lot of bronze doors in the Dwightway, aren't there? The Florentines love a bronze door. While that's happening, what's happened to Giuliano? When the bell rang, Giuliano bowed his head as Lorenzo had, and the guys on his side were much more efficient. Baroncelli, the adventurer, struck first. He shouted, take that, you traitor!
他狠狠地向他的头部砍去，显然差点把它劈成两半。然后弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐扑了上去。他一次又一次地刺向他的胸膛。朱利亚诺倒在血泊中。弗朗切斯科像疯子一样疯狂地刺杀。总共19处伤口。所以一滩血在圣坛上蔓延开来。完全正确。
Slashed at his head so fiercely, it's you almost split it in two, apparently. And then Francesco de Pazzi was on him. He stabbed him in the chest again and again. Giuliano fell to the floor with blood everywhere. Francesco like a madman stabbing furiously. 19 wounds in all. So a puddle of blood spreading over the Holy Altar. Exactly.
两个杀手抬起头。他们看到洛伦佐正朝大门跑去。他们向他追去。他们想在到达大门前截住他。但就在这时，一个极被忽视的人，一个名叫弗朗切斯科·诺里的美第奇银行合伙人、洛伦佐的朋友，冲出来干预了。这其实是美第奇家族历史上至关重要的时刻。诺里挡在他们的去路上。
The two killers look up. They can see Lorenzo running for the doors. They run after him. They want to cut him off before he gets to the doors. But at that point, a very unappreciated man, a man called Francesco Nori, who's a partner in the Medici bank, a mate of Lorenzo's, he rushes in to intervene. A crucial moment actually in the whole story of the Medici dynasty. Nori throw himself in their path.
巴伦切利猛地刺出匕首刺死了他。但正因如此，他们失去了宝贵的几秒钟。洛伦佐和他的几个朋友得以穿过圣器室的门，猛地关上并在身后反锁。所以他现在安全了。现在的教堂成了一个完全混乱和骚动的地方。人们在奔跑尖叫。
Barancelli plunged his dagger in and stabbed him and killed him. But in doing so, they lost vital seconds. Lorenzo and a couple of his friends were able to get through the sacristy doors, slam them shut and jam them behind them. So now he's safe. So now the cathedral, a scene of total chaos and uproar. There are people running and screaming.
朱利亚诺尸体上的血泊四处蔓延。据说在主祭坛前，对这一切一无所知的里里奥枢机主教惊呆得目瞪口呆，随后被紧急护送到安全地带。但事后据说他的脸再也没有恢复过当时在祭坛前的那种苍白。我完全相信。是的。他没有料到这一点。我觉得公平地说，托姆，
There's this puddle of blood from Giuliano's body spreading everywhere. It was said that the high altar, Cardinal Riario, who knew nothing about this, was standing there like gaping in shock and was rushed to safety. But it was said afterwards that his face never lost the pallor that it had had at that moment at the altar. I can well believe it. Yeah. He wasn't expecting it. I think it's fair to say, Tom.
事情的发展并不像他想象的那样。现在，与此同时，洛伦佐怎么样了？洛伦佐的朋友们把他仓促护送出大教堂的后门回到了美第奇宫。美第奇宫外聚集了巨大的人群，他走了出来，脖子上还流着血，但很明显他还活着。他说：“你知道的，发生了一场政变，我们必须奋起反击阴谋家。”
The day had not unfolded as he imagined. Now, meanwhile, what's happened to Lorenzo? Lorenzo's friends kind of bustled him out to the back door of the cathedral to the Medici Palace. A great crowd assembles outside the Medici Palace and he comes out and he's kind of bleeding from his neck, but he's still very clearly alive. And he says, you know, there's a coup, we must fight back against the conspirators.
现在，与此同时，大主教萨尔维亚蒂怎么样了，他带着雇佣兵向西诺利亚宫进发，但他被吓了一跳。他以为议员们会——你知道的，他能轻松搞定他们——但并没有，他们反抗了。佛罗伦萨的标准旗手，宫廷旗手，显然抓起了一根烤肉叉，亲自同大主教对抗。议员们开始敲响大钟“瓦卡”，呼吁支援。大量的人涌入广场。他们的数量完全压倒了阴谋分子和雇佣兵，他们高呼着响亮的口号：“维瓦诺拉佩”（Vivano la PE），万岁，为了睾丸万岁。
Now, meanwhile, what happened to the Archbishop, Salviati, he had marched on the Palazzo della Signoria with his mercenaries, but he was taken aback. He thought the counselors would be, you know, he'd be able to kind of steamroll with them, but no, they fought back. The standard bearer of Florence, the gonfalonieri, apparently grabbed a cooking spit and fought back against the archbishop personally. The council start ringing the big bell, the vacca, calling for aid. Loads of people pour into the square. They completely outnumber the plotters and the mercenaries and they're chanting spendedly, Vivano la PE, long live the balls, hurrah for the balls.
所以那是来自美第奇的徽章，药丸纹章，是的。没错。所以这些人高喊着关于睾丸的口号，最终屠杀了大主教所有的雇佣兵。他们砍下他们的头颅，然后拿着这些插在长矛上的头颅在城里横行。大主教被逼入绝境。他们在他的脖子上套了一根绳子，然后把他从西诺利亚宫的一扇高层窗户扔了出去，任由他在那里悬挂着。
So that's from the Medici symbol, the Cote de Farms, yeah. Exactly. So these people chanting about balls, they end up slaughtering all of the archbishop's mercenaries. They cut off their heads and then they rampage around the city with these heads on lances. The archbishop, he was cornered. They tied a rope around his neck and then they threw him out of an upper window of the Palazzo De La Signoria and they left him to dangle there
我觉得这很公平，现在是银行经理弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐。他们找到了他。他们剥光了他的衣服。他们对他也做了同样的事。你想听一个血腥的事实吗？说吧。这两个家伙挂在绳子上痛苦地挣扎，还有那个大主教。据说当他在绳子尽头挣扎着快要死的时候，由于某种奇怪的原因，他狠狠地咬了弗朗切斯科·德·帕齐的胸口一大口，把牙齿深深嵌进他的躯干里。你知道这就像什么吗？就像《但丁神曲》里的情景。确实有点像，不是吗？
I think that's fair enough and now Francesco de Pazzi the bank manager. They found him. They stripped him naked They did the same thing to him. Would you like a gory fact go up? Go for it. These two blokes dangling from the ropes and kind of writhing and agony and the Archbishop It was said what he was writhing at the end of his rope about to die for some peculiar reason he took a massive bite out of Francesco de Paz's chest and sank his teeth into his torso. You know what it's like something out of Dante's Inferno. It is a bit isn't it.
可怕的场面。但这其实是一件可怕的事，因为它演变成了一场大规模的骚乱，大约有80人，其中许多人完全是无辜的，遭到私刑处决，直到洛伦佐设法平息了局势。那么其他阴谋分子怎么样了？所以我们提到过，那个你一开始提到的家伙马菲，命中注定要挨刀子。他确实如此。
Hideous scene. Well it actually is a hideous thing because it turns into a massive riot and about 80 people, many of them completely innocent, were lynched until Lorenzo managed to calm things down. So what happened to the other plotters? So we mentioned that that bloke, Maffei, who you began with, had an appointment with the knife. He did indeed.
他和另外几名神父被抓住了，他们被阉割了，然后其中一人被绞死，一人被斩首。这就是他们的结局。蒙泰塞科，那个身经百战的雇佣兵队长，在严刑拷打下受审。这就是我们了解故事细节的原因。然后他得到了一个稍微温和一点的结局，就是在巴杰罗（Bargello）庭院里被剑斩首，巴杰罗现在是一个非常著名的艺术雕塑博物馆。但如果他透露了所有细节，我的意思是，他也没那么铁石心肠，对吧？
He and the other priests, they were caught, they were castrated, and then one of them was hanged and one of them was beheaded. So that was the end of them. Monteseco, the sort of hard-bitten mercenary captain, he was interrogated under torture. That's how we know the details of the story. And then he had a slightly more benign end in that he was beheaded with a sword in the courtyard of the Bargello, which is now a very famous art sculpture museum. But if he revealed all the details, I mean, he's not that heart-bitten, is he?
别忘了，他之前一直担心上帝会在大教堂里看到他。这倒也是，是的。所以他显然从头到尾都有怀疑。然后那个杀死朱利亚诺的冒险家巴伦切利逃到了君士坦丁堡。但他在君士坦丁堡不知怎么被人认出来了，苏丹同意将他引渡回佛罗伦萨，他最终也在巴杰罗被斩首。这就是他的结局。
Don't forget, he had been worried that God would see him in the cathedral. That's true, yeah. So he clearly had doubts the whole time. And then the adventurer, Barancelli, who killed Giuliani, he escaped as far as Constantinople. But he was recognized somehow in Constantinople, and the Sultan agreed to extradite him to Florence and he ended up being beheaded in the Bargello as well. So that was what happened to him.
那么教父帕齐家族的雅科波呢？他逃到一个村庄，人们认出了他，他被拖回了佛罗伦萨。这其实是一个非常血腥的结局。他遭受了酷刑，被剥光了衣服，同样被挂在西诺利亚宫的窗户上。所以那是首选的处决风格。非常如此，非常符合这种氛围。他的尸体被扔进阿诺河，但一些孩子随后把它捞了出来，孩子们把它挂在一棵柳树上，为了自娱自乐，他们过去殴打它、鞭笞它。那是个更单纯的年代。
Now what about the godfather, the Pazzi Jacopo? He fled to a village, people recognized him, he was dragged back to Florence. This is a very gory end actually. He was tortured, he was stripped naked, he again was hanged from a window of the Palazzo della Signoria. So that's the style of execution of choice. Very much so, very much the vibe. His body was thrown into the River Arno but some children then fished it out and children hung it from a willow tree and to amuse themselves used to go and beat it and flog it. It's more innocent times.
他在那儿挂了多久？我不知道，但总比闷在家里玩PlayStation强吧？我的意思是，我觉得出去走走找点乐子挺好的。我想是的。在这一切的过程中，他的头掉了下来。人们把它带到帕齐宫。他们自娱自乐地用它敲门，就像把它当门环一样。哦天哪。所以他本来应该听从自己的直觉，不是吗？他应该听从自己的直觉。这是一个永远不要违背自己直觉的标志。帕齐家族被永远驱逐出佛罗伦萨。他们的财产被没收。他们的象征海豚被从城里抹去。甚至如果你娶了帕齐家族的人，你也被
How long was it hanging there? I don't know but it's better than being stuck inside in a PlayStation, no? I mean I think it's good to get outside and have some fun. I suppose so. And in the course of all this his head came off. People took it to the Palazzo Patson. They used to amuse themselves by banging it on the door, like using it as a door knocker. Oh God. So he should have gone with his original instincts, shouldn't he? He should have gone with his instincts. It's a sign never go against your instincts. The Pazzi family were banished forever from Florence. Their property confiscated. Their symbol, which was the dolphin, was erased from the city. Even if you'd married a Pazzi, you were
永远禁止担任公职。实际上波提切利在执行死刑的巴杰罗画了一幅精美的壁画。一幅精美的壁画，画着脖子上套着绳子、摇摇晃晃走向死亡的帕齐家族成员。所以这挺好的。现在，事实上，在全欧洲，帕齐阴谋是个大新闻。每个人都对它感到非常震惊。法兰西国王路易十一写信给洛伦佐说，天哪，多么可怕的事情。在弥撒上做这种事实在难以置信。我的意思是，他没说错。我觉得那太令人震惊了。不，我觉得你应该多听听教皇的话。
banned forever from holding office. And actually Botticelli painted a lovely mural at the Bargello where the executions had taken place. A lovely mural of the patsy with ropes around their necks kind of dangling to their deaths. So that's nice. Now, actually, across Europe, the Patsy Conspiracy was a great story. Everyone was very shocked by it. The King of France, Louis XI, he wrote to Lorenzo saying, gosh, what a terrible story. Unbelievable to do it at mass. I mean, he's not wrong. I find that very shocking. No, I think you should pay more heed to the pope.
教皇说，这完全没有什么不对，真正的罪魁祸首其实是美第奇家族。你知道他做了什么吗？当他听到阴谋失败的消息时，他立刻将洛伦佐和整个佛罗伦萨市政当局逐出了教会。他说这是因为杀害了两名神父和大主教。他认为这绝对是无耻之尤。你听到天主教徒抱怨，我不知道，弗朗西斯或者别的什么。觉醒教皇。觉醒教皇。你必须说，我的意思是。
The pope said, there's absolutely nothing wrong with this and the real miscreants here are the Medici. Do you know what he did? When he heard about the failure of the plots, he promptly excommunicated Lorenzo and the entire Signoria of Florence. He said for killing the two priests and the archbishop. He thought that was absolutely disgraceful. You hear Catholics complaining about, I don't know, Francis or whatever. Woke popes. Woke popes. You have to say, I mean.
我觉得西克斯图斯是个更有魄力的教皇。跟西克斯图斯四世比起来，这显得太软弱无力了。西克斯图斯四世是个非常有魄力的教皇，我觉得。跟西克斯图斯四世比起来，这显得太软弱无力了。西克斯图斯四世是个非常有魄力的教皇。现在，洛伦佐对佛罗伦萨议会说，听着，我们现在面临的是教皇反对我们的局面。我可以流亡。他知道他们会说不，但他说，我可以流亡。
Sixtus is a more robust pope, I think. It looks pretty feeble compared to Sixtus the fourth. Sixtus the fourth is a very robust pope, I think. It looks pretty feeble compared to Sixtus IV. Sixtus IV is a very robust pope. Now, Lorenzo said to the council of Florence, look, we're up against here with the pope against us. I could go into exile. He knows that they'll say no, but he says, I could go into exile.
每个人都说，哦，不，别那样。我们会团结一致。我们会捍卫美第奇家族，就像捍卫我们自己的共和国一样。但在1478年6月底，西克斯图斯将佛罗伦萨置于禁令之下，我相信托姆，这意味着在佛罗伦萨没有人可以领受圣事，他们不能领圣餐。是的，他们不被允许出生或死亡或诸如此类的事。没错，他实际上随后发布了——这就像乔治·W·布什的邪恶轴心国什么的——他说，我呼吁所有其他意大利国家。
And everybody said, oh, no, don't do that. We'll all stand together. We'll defend the House of Medici as we will defend our own republic. But at the end of June 1478, Sixtus placed Florence under interdict, which I believe Tom, means that no one can take the sacraments, they can't take communion in Florence. Yeah, and they're not allowed to be born or die or anything like that. Right, and he actually then issued, it's like George W Bush in the Axis of Evil or something, he said, I call on all the other Italian states.
让我们对被逐出教会且异端邪说的洛伦佐·德·美第奇采取自由干预行动。你知道的，上帝希望我们基本上惩罚他的邪恶。美第奇银行被驱逐出罗马和那不勒斯。其资产被没收。几周后，听从教皇的号召，那不勒斯王位继承人、卡拉布里亚公爵阿方索带着大军离开那不勒斯，直奔佛罗伦萨。所以对洛伦佐来说，局势现在看起来有点绝望了。他真的很需要钱来组建军队，但实际上他把所有的钱都花在华丽的
Let's stage a liberal intervention against the excommunicated and heretical Lorenzo de Medici. You know, God wants us to basically punish him for his wickedness. The Medici bank was expelled from Rome and from Naples. Its assets were seized. And a few weeks later, heeding the Pope's call, the heir to the throne of Naples, who was Alfonso Duke of Calabria, left Naples with the big army heading for Florence. So things are looking a bit desperate now for Lorenzo. He really needs money to raise an army, but actually he's blown all his money on fancy
头盔上，还有带有种马和祭坛画的昂贵东西以及所有这些。圣母领报。是的，完全正确。所以他不得不派遣信使穿梭于意大利各地乞求现金，特别是向米兰。他把家人送到位于佛罗伦萨以北山区的卡法吉奥洛美第奇城堡以求安全。几个月过去了，阿方索进展非常缓慢，基本上是一步一个脚印地穿过意大利中部。
helmets and stuff with stallions and altarpieces and all of this. Annunciations. Yeah, exactly. So he has to send messengers across Italy to beg for cash, especially to Milan. He sends his family to the Medici castle at Cafagiolo, which is in the mountains north of Florence, for safety. The months go by and Alfonso makes very slow progress, basically grinding his way through central Italy.
攻克一个又一个城镇，一个又一个城堡，直奔佛罗伦萨。阿方索进展非常缓慢，基本上是一步一个脚印地穿过意大利中部，攻克一个又一个城镇，一个又一个城堡，直奔佛罗伦萨。战争拖延下去了。它在佛罗伦萨经济上掏空了一个大洞。人们开始断粮。发生了抢粮骚乱。你知道的，阿方索和在教皇支持下的那不勒斯军队越来越近了。
Take town by town, castle by castle, heading for Florence. Alfonso makes very slow progress, basically grinding his way through central Italy, take town by town, castle by castle, heading for Florence. The war drags on. It blows a hole in the Florentine economy. People start running out of food. There are bread riots. You know, Alfonso and the Neapolitan army with the Pope's backing is getting closer and closer.
在1479年夏末，一位朋友写信给洛伦佐说，你知道的，佛罗伦萨已经精疲力竭了。人们只是希望这一切结束。你知道的，现在发生了抢粮骚乱，必须有所改变了。然后洛伦佐做出了一个非同寻常的决定。这是一个重磅炸弹吗？这是一个重磅炸弹。我们在这集里还没有过重磅炸弹，但现在有了。
In the late summer of 1479, a friend writes to Lorenzo and says, you know, Florence is exhausted. People just want this to end. You know, there were bread riots now, something has to change. And then Lorenzo comes to a really extraordinary decision. Is it a bombshell? It is a bombshell. We haven't had a bombshell in this episode, but now we have.
1479年12月5日，他向市政当局发送了一条消息。他说：“我已经下定决心了。为了和平，我将做出终极牺牲。”他说：“鉴于我们城市所处危险的境地，审议的时间已经结束。是采取行动的时候了。我决定立即启程前往那不勒斯。我是我们城市敌人的主要目标，所以我决定将自己交到他们手中，也许这样我们就能获得和平。这场战争始于我和我兄弟的鲜血，也许这就是上帝的意愿，这就是我们结束它的方式。”所以托姆，一场令人难以置信的赌博。花花公子、艺术赞助人洛伦佐将要
On the 5th of December, 1479, he sends a message to the Signoria. He says, I made my mind up. I'm going to make the ultimate sacrifice for peace. He says, given the dangerous circumstances in which our city is placed, the time for deliberation is over. It is time for action. I have decided to sail for Naples immediately. I am the chief target of our city's enemies, so I have decided to surrender myself into their hands and perhaps that way we will have peace. The war began with the blood of my brother and of myself, and perhaps such as the will of God, that this is how we will end it." So Tom, an incredible gamble. Lorenzo, the playboy, the patron of the arts, is going to
1479年12月5日，他向执政团发去了一条消息。他说，我已经下定决心。我将为和平做出最终的牺牲。他说，鉴于我们城市所处危险的境地，商议的时刻已经结束，现在是采取行动的时候了。我已决定立即起航前往那不勒斯。我是我们城市敌人的主要目标，所以我决定把自己交到他们手中，也许这样我们就能迎来和平。这场战争以我弟弟和我自己的鲜血开始，也许这就是上帝的旨意，我们将以此来结束它。" 所以，汤姆，这是一场难以置信的赌博。洛伦佐，这位花花公子、艺术赞助人，正打算
risk his freedom, perhaps even his life to save the people of Florence. Goodness, stunning stuff. If you want to know what happens, you can find out right now by joining the Rest is History club at therestishistory.com. And not only will you find out what happens to Lorenzo, but you will get to hear about his giraffe, which is for me, the highlight of the whole series. And of course you get episode four as well, the last in the
冒着失去自由甚至生命的危险去拯救佛罗伦萨的人民。天哪，太精彩了。如果你想知道接下来会发生什么，现在就可以访问 therestishistory.com 加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部。不仅能知道洛伦佐的结局，还能听到关于他那只长颈鹿的故事对我来说，那是整个系列中最亮眼的亮点。当然，你还可以听到第四集，也就是本系列的最后一集
series, Savonarola, Bonfire of the Vanities, all of that. But if you want to wait, that's fine. It will be coming out next Monday and next Thursday, episodes three and four. So thank Thanks everyone for listening and bye bye. Garcia Riverace. mentioned earlier on. When I look back on it now, you still see that, you know, there's plans, there's memoranda, there's notifications, there's all these things, but they're never actually executed. They never actually kind of pull the trigger on anything, do they? I'm a little bit of two minds on this because I agree with you that the theme of this episode really is a series of missed opportunities to get Osama bin Laden prior to 9-11. But we should also note that once Tenet and the CIA understand that Osama bin Laden is coming for us, in particular after the East Africa bombings, there is a push to improve our collection
萨沃纳罗拉、虚荣之火，应有尽有。但如果你想等也没关系。第三集和第四集将于下周一和下周四播出。感谢大家的收听，再见。加西亚·里瓦切斯。刚才提到过。现在回想起来，你仍然会发现，你知道，有计划、有备忘录、有通知，有所有这些东西，但它们从来没有真正被执行过。他们从来没有真正对任何事情扣动扳机，对吧？我对这件事持两种态度，因为我同意你的看法，本集的真正主题是9·11之前错失了一系列抓捕本·拉登的机会。但我们也应该注意到，一旦特尼特和中情局明白本·拉登是冲着我们来的，特别是在东非大使馆爆炸案之后，他们就会推动改善情报搜集
and our understanding of Al-Qaeda pretty significantly. I mean, there's a bunch of human sources who get recruited in this period. There's a lot more technical collection. Alex Station is beefed up to more than 40 people. There's a bunch of connections with foreign partners on Al-Qaeda that hadn't existed before. I mean, interestingly, there's a PDB president's daily brief in December, December the fourth of 1998, which is titled quote, Bin Laden preparing to hijack US aircraft and other attacks. And so there's a lot of strategic warning, I think you
以及我们对基地组织的理解，程度相当显著。我的意思是，这一时期招募了大量的人力情报来源。有更多的技术搜集手段。亚历山大情报站的兵力扩充到40多人。与外国伙伴建立了许多以前不存在的关于基地组织的联系。有趣的是，1998年12月4日有一份总统每日简报（PDB），其标题是“本·拉登正准备劫持美国飞机和其他袭击”。因此我认为有很多战略预警
could say about what Al Qaeda is up to. And yet there's an inability, I think, to translate that into practical efforts and operations to stop these attacks and just stop Al-Qaeda from ultimately carrying out 9-11. If you want to hear the full episode, listen to the rest is classified wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以说出基地组织在搞什么名堂。然而，我认为人们无法将这些转化为阻止这些袭击的实际努力和行动，也无法阻止基地组织最终实施9·11事件。如果你想听完整的一集，请在各大播客平台收听 The Rest is Classified。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。